à
en
tout cas
à
alors bonjour et bienvenue à ce forum
solution pour le pour le climat nous
sommes en direct sur le site internet de
radio-canada également sur facebook et
surtout à la maison du développement
durable ici à montréal donc merci à ceux
qui sont présents aujourd'hui on prend
environ deux heures pour parler de
solution concrète pour
atténuer les effets des changements
climatiques et on a réuni quatre experts
qui peuvent aborder vraiment différents
volets de tout saute donc on va vous les
présenter relativement rapidement et on
veut passer le maximum de temps à
répondre aux questions du public et dans
la salle et également par internet donc
encore une fois si vous nous suivez sur
internet vous avez une petite boîte de
dialogue qui pour qui peut vous servir
envoyer des questions johan la terre
vous expliquera tout ça dans un moment
mais d'abord je vous présente nos
invités monsieur jacquet donc c'est la
saint jacques et consultant en bâtiment
durable et chargé de cours à l'école de
technologie supérieure
de montréal oui bien sûr d'être là et
les clans comprends que vous avez
collaboré un peu au développement ou
l'idéation de la maison du développement
durable oui effectivement un cancan la
maison du développement durable a été
construite un des volets importants de
bâtiments écologiques c'est l'aspect
l'aspect éducation donc moi j'avais une
expertise de par mes études sur les
toits verts ici un toit vert kit un kit
intéressant à regarder donc on va
consulter à l'occasion pour ça merci
beaucoup alors madame isabelle lessard
coordonnatrice scientifique du centre
interdisciplinaire de recherche en
opérationnalisation du développement
durable le cirad merci d'être là associé
à la polytechnique
on y associer à la polytechnique nom et
1500 n'est vraiment un regroupement de
chercheurs qui proviennent de onze
institutions universitaires quatre
cégeps et puis on est localisée à
polytechnique mais la mission c'est
vraiment c'est dans
l'opérationnalisation donc d'être très
concret donc
de rendre la recherche
démocratiser la recherche puis de sortir
les chercheurs de leur université
travailler avec les acteurs de terrain
par exemple
fabriqué créé concevoir des outils
opérationnels exemple aujourd'hui
de vous avoir avec nous monsieur denis
lapointe vous êtes maire de salaberry de
valleyfield est également président de
la commission de l'environnement de
l'union des municipalités du québec
merci d'être là merci de votre
invitation dans le contexte de la
conférence de paris et d'allemand les
élus vont interpeller hormis chez centre
être concernés par les changements
climatiques en fait on les vit
directement puis on va aussi vivent tous
et ses décisions qui vont être prises à
paris vont atterrir à quelque part est
généralement c'est dans les milieux
urbains c'est nous qui ont à mettre en
application les politiques qui sont
choisis établi les orientations et on
est sur le terrain c'est encore
jean-christophe amado ou travailler chez
deloitte donc vous conseiller les
entreprises dans leur développement
durable dans leurs initiatives
autant pour l'atténuation que
l'adaptation au changement climatique
gestion de risque aussi dans certains
cas tout à fait le cas chez donc c'est
intéressant de vous avoir également avec
nous est ce que vous travailler
davantage avec les petites entreprises
où les grandes entreprises on travaille
à la fois avec les pme ou les
multinationales
c'est vrai que souvent les
multinationales ont de plus gros budget
pour essayer d'aller plus loin dans
leurs réponses au changement climatique
d'aller au delà de leur conformité à des
obligations réglementaires ou légale mon
travail avec les uns avec les deux
secteurs et on travaille aussi avec le
secteur public
est au bout de la table johanne lapierre
qui se veut le relais des questions du
public alors peut-être joie nous
expliquer comment tout ça va en faire
fonctionner oui alors pour tous ceux qui
nous écoutent sur différentes
plateformes numériques si vous êtes sur
facebook on vous invite à réagir en
direct à ce que tous les invités vont
dire si vous avez des questions
également leur poser on est vraiment là
pour ça moi je vais donc vérifier sur
toutes les plateformes quelle question
je peux relayé aux invités donc la
parole est vraiment à vous si vous êtes
sur facebook sous la vidéo vous pouvez
envoyer vos commentaires si vous êtes
sûr ici radio canada.ca baroud des
climats vous avez une petite fenêtre en
direct sur le côté sur laquelle vous
pouvez également poser vos questions sur
youtube également va prendre vos
commentaires et si vous êtes sur twitter
vous pouvez commenter avec le mot-clic
forum climat et pour tous les gens qui
sont dans la salle ici il ya un micro
qui est placé juste sur le côté donc si
à tout instant vous avez une question
aux commentaires désiré l'ancien éviter
rendez-vous micro et puis je vais vous
aider la parole alors je vais je vais
être attentif à ce qui se passe dans la
salle aussi très bien moi j'avais envie
de commencer avec quelque chose de très
concret parce qu'on sait tous ce qui se
passe à paris présentement les le ballet
diplomatique on espère que ça donnera
quelque chose évidemment ça conscientise
tout le monde on est on s'inscrit
directement dans ce dans ce grand forum
là des idées concrètes lorsque je suis
allé faire un tour sur le site internet
de la coop 21 on nous donnait dix gestes
concrets pour que nous à la maison on
puisse améliorer quelque chose
j'aimerais vous entendre sur
vous avant de vous de parler de ces
éléments là vous si une chose qui au
quotidien dans votre travail peut
vraiment faire quelque chose de concret
ce serait quoi je vois chez de la tête
madame madame lessard a commencé avec
vous
c'est
aujourd'hui que ça va être assez de
prendre du recul pour avoir une vision
globale des événements on parle beaucoup
des gaz à effet de serre ges et tout
mais quelque part tout est interconnecté
il faut pas séparer les gs de la
pollution de l'air l'eau l'environnement
et tout ce qu'il faut aussi apprendre à
travailler ensemble au travers tout ça
parce que là ce qui arrive quand on
travaille trop dans les petites boîtes
séparer je pense que moi je pense que
toutes les boîtes ils sont là ils sont
présentes il ya il ya cette chose ce qui
manque c'est le mariage entre ses
boucles et donc c'est un peu le
plaidoyer que je vais faire aujourd'hui
c'est d'avoir plus de liaisons autant au
travers les différentes linke aussi de
regarder les impacts globalement pas
juste regarder gs mais de prendre du
recul que de regarder l'ensemble de tout
ça parce que tout est interconnecté
parler de prendre les choses globalement
et vous intéresser notamment au cycle de
vie des produits donc on aura sans doute
l'occasion d'en reparler parce que ça
fait ne me fait quelque chose qui
revient souvent à quel point on doit
changer nos produits énergivores pour
d'autres et dans toute la consommation
comment les produits ont des effets sur
l'environnement
monsieur jacquet vous de votre côté
quotidiennement j'en comprends que dans
le développement durable dans le
bâtiment durable et beaucoup de choses à
faire est qu'on croyait effectivement
effectivement dans le bâtiment puisque
c'est ce que j'essaie de transmettre
comme message à mes étudiants à chaque
session
quand on fait un bâtiment sicile et
c'est bien de faire le plus
écoénergétique possible si bien le faire
le plus vert possible mais si on regarde
un peu puis bon des ingénieurs on aime
beaucoup les chiffres que je commence
tout de suite et je vous en donne plein
si on regarde l'empreinte mettons
écologique d'un d'un québécois d'une
famille québécoise il ya un peu de gaz à
effet de serre qui proviennent de son
habitation je dis bien un peu là
peut-être de l'ordre de 20 à 30 % une
grande majorité de nos gaz à effet de
serre viennent de notre transport alors
peut-être la chose qu'on pourrait faire
en premier lieu par nos bâtiments c'est
de choisir de façon intelligente le lieu
où est ce qu'on va les installer
si je dis tout le temps si on fabrique
un bâtiment très très écologique mais
qu'on les installe dans un lieu désert
où il ya pas de service où il ya peu de
transport et et que les usagers sont
obligés de se déplacer pour hills pour
s'y rendre est ce que vraiment notre
bâtiment et écologique selon moi non
donc peut-être un message qu'on pourrait
que que sur lequel je promets de
l'emphase tout de suite maintenant c'est
choisir intelligemment ou est-ce qu'on
habite choisir intelligemment où est ce
qu'on va construire ou notre lieu de
résidence peut avoir un impact très très
grand sur notre sur notre empreinte
d'espoir évidemment fait se fait pas
tout seul ce sont des politiques
davantage au niveau
à l'échelle communautaire et à ce moment
là monsieur lapointe ce sont vous les
élus qui généralement devait composer
avec cette architecture est beaucoup
plus grande échelle pour développer des
projets de développement durable oui les
élus doivent vivre avec les conséquences
des décisions qui sont prises mais en
fait la personne clé dans toute cette
réduction dans toute cette bataille
c'est le citoyen citoyens la citoyenne
est en fête tout démarre de la est le
mot que je rêve d'utiliser ses
consommations si j'ai un terme à
utiliser consommation comment on peut
arriver à réduire notre consommation et
les pratiques courantes de chaque
individu on peut changer nos habitudes
de vie
quotidienne on peut changer nos
habitudes de vie hebdomadaire et faire
en sorte que dans nos nouvelles
pratiques ont réduit cette consommation
là ils ont réduisent notre empreinte sur
la production de gaz à effet de serre et
dans nos tâches domestiques en fait
accentuée l'a
augmentée c'est à dire le recyclage
se doter d'équipements dans les maisons
qui vont réduire
les la consommation d'eau changer notre
consommation d'eau aussi à l'intérieur
des grands consommateurs d'eau changer
notre pratique aussi dans la gestion de
matières résiduelles on a des gestes
qu'on peut poser comme individu qui
collectivement va avoir un impact
important dans nos communautés puis dans
le reste
de nos territoires occupés est ce que
les municipalités sont outillés pour
faire ça c'est à dire que évidemment il
ya plusieurs paliers gouvernementaux
mais à quel point le geste au quotidien
de l'individu qui ferment le robinet
quand il se brosse les dents ou sauve
une minute dans la douche pour
économiser de l'eau à quel point tout ça
d'un effet de grandeur par rapport à
tout ce qui conseille et vous imaginez
la ville que je représente quarante
mille personnes montréal un million deux
millions de personnes fait ses petites
additions là à chaque jour multiplié par
le nombre de personnes qui sont là vous
avez un impact majeur on peut même des
villes se sont engagés à inviter leurs
citoyens à réduire d'une tonne par année
l'heure les effets ou là leur production
de gaz à effet de serre par les gestes
au quotidien on peut réussir cab toute
petite pratique arrive à éliminer ces
s'étonne la est multiple il s'est encore
parfois plus important que ce qui est
produit dans une industrie par exemple
il ya un effet cumulatif il ya des
exemples qu'on peut redonner au cours de
la journée au cours de la présentation
maintenant et qui vont démontrer qu'un
petit résultats additionnés à d'autres
que ces résultats font de grands
résultats
j'entends déjà les gens
oui les petits résultats sous des gestes
citoyens mais au final ce sont les
grandes entreprises qui émettent des
tonnes de gaz à effet de serre et ce
sont vers elle qu'on devrait se tourner
j'aime ados comment vous interagissez
avec les grandes entreprises est ce
qu'elles sont toutes dans une logique
écologistes ou au delà du grand habit
vert il n'y a pas également des
impératifs de production et
économiques qui font en sorte qu'ils
n'ont pas vraiment intérêt à investir
autant que les citoyens pourraient
vouloir le faire il s'agit de
problématiques complexes qu'il faut pas
oublier que les entreprises qu'elles
soient grandes ou petites sont quand
même créatrice d'emplois sont elles qui
sont au coeur de la croissance
économique dans nos sociétés
donc il est le changement climatique
crée des risques et des opportunités
d'affaires pour ces clients là pour les
entreprises et je dirais que
le canada une plus ou moins mauvaise
réputation depuis pas mal d'années sur
sa performance en matière de gestion
climatique on a un nouveau gueule
nouveau gouvernement fédéral en place
qui plus favorables à la réduction des
gaz à effet de serre et aux politiques
climatiques et les entreprises
canadiennes de manière intéressante sont
depuis là c'est longtemps en fait assez
favorable à la mise en place de
politiques de gestion climatique plus en
plus strictes et plus proactives donc
par exemple c'est pas surprenant de voir
que lorsque le premier ministre de
l'alberta a fait l'annoncé de la
nouvelle stratégie en matière de
réduction de gaz à effet de serre il ya
une semaine ou deux elle avait derrière
elle les plus grands dirigeants secteurs
de l'énergie de l'alberta qui qui qui
sont plus ou moins favorables à ces
politiques là parce que ça crée ça crée
une un certain niveau de certitude
sachant par amp le prix que le
gouvernement va mettre sur une tonne de
carbone sachant les politiques qui vont
être mises en place ces entreprises là
ensuite peuvent faire les
investissements qui vont à qui vont
engendrer le la plus grosse
profitabilité pour le long terme de
votre point de vue quand vous conseillez
des entreprises est ce que ces
entreprises sont davantage en mode
adaptation changement climatique ou
atténuation des effets
néfaste pour l'environnement quel est le
point de vue qui transcende parce que
bon il ya une prise de conscience on le
sent depuis des années vers des écoles d
une économie plus verte mais à quel
point ça se traduit vraiment dans les
gestes concrets il ya des volontés
est-ce que c'est davantage au niveau des
pme justement que cette volonté ou des
grands dirigeants de grandes entreprises
avec justement des
des règles qui sont très différentes
d'un bout à l'autre de la planète
comment elle voit sa ces grandes
entreprises ouais bah les les dirigeants
de grosses entreprises de plusieurs
années maintenant
ce au canada au travers du monde ont des
obligations en matière de réduction de
gaz à effet de serre la plupart sont
pris sous le coup d'un de réglementation
de législation en matière de
taxe de carbone ou des changes de droits
à polluer
donc la main elles sont dans une optique
de conformité et la plupart d'entre
elles ont des actionnaires qui leur
demande de faire des efforts au delà des
politiques réglementaires puisqu'elles
savent que sur le long terme on va
devoir réduire nos gaz à effet de serre
maintenant au niveau des pme je pense
qu'il ya une vraie volonté de participer
à cet effort collectif
mais c'est vrai que les incitatifs
économiques financiers ne sont pas
forcément là et
celles ci ne sont pas forcément outillés
vont pouvoir le faire de manière de
manière profitable
johan peut-être que des questions mais
tout de suite dire on est entre nous et
il n'y aura pas de période de questions
après notre discussion donc c'est ici et
maintenant vous êtes invités à poser des
questions si vous en avez au micro ça va
orienter notre notre discussion au cours
des prochaines minutes alors n'hésitez
pas il ya un micro dans la salle pour
les personnes qui voudraient qu'ils
voudraient poser des questions
évidemment sur internet on en a déjà
reçu oui alors ben j'en ai une je sais
pas si ça va toucher par exemple un
nouveau experts qui va pouvoir donner
une solution à ça mais c'est quelqu'un
qui dit bonjour je tendais de verre au
quotidien mais je me sens coupable de
prendre l'avion deux fois par an que
puis-je faire est ce que on n'a pas
nécessairement quelqu'un de l'expand
transports mais est ce que quelqu'un qui
sont aussi à répondre et est-ce qu'il
faut sentir coupable comme gens d'une
certaine par rapport à tout le reste
mais oui à l'elysée monsieur amadou non
il est clair que les le monde de
transport aérien est très consommateur
en gaz est fait
ce qu'on vous entende aujourd'hui non
mais de manière concrète il existe il
est possible de prendre des actions pour
réduire ses gaz à effet de serre là il
existe des crédits compensatoires 1 que
les particuliers ou les entreprises
peuvent acheter pour compenser ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
associées au transport aérien et ses
crédits compensatoires là bas c'est
comme tout il va la voir des très peu
chers dont la crédibilité va peut-être
être un peu douteuse et veut y en avoir
d très crédible et c'est beaucoup plus
cher beaucoup plus coûteux qui sont
également disponibles
j'avais le goût de réagir parce que je
pense qu'on peut pas séparer nos gestes
les gestes de notre vie il ya des choses
qu'on fait oui qui amène une certaine
consommation mais une certaine
production de gaz à effet de serre mais
il ya d'autres gestes qu'on peut poser
qu'ils peuvent être compensatoires si on
dans notre plan de vie ou dans notre
façon de gérer notre vie comme citoyen
on adapte des pratiques qui visent à
réduire au maximum parfois pas
s'empêcher de vivre non plus et faire en
sorte que mon pc éventuellement voyager
se déplacer si on conserve encore même
dans ses déplacements des pratiques
des pratiques écologiques finalement
alors faut pas s'empêcher de vie et puis
faire en sorte que ça soit plus
intéressante dit je pense qu'il faut
adopter une façon différente et
maintenant et continue à profiter de son
voyage deux fois par année on habite
notre maison au quotidien j'en comprends
que vous vous intéressez monsieur
jacques et particulièrement aux mesures
qu'on peut prendre lors de la
construction d'une maison lors de la
rénovation d'une maison donnez-nous dont
deux trois trucs qui nous dit comme ça
pour que si on a des raynaud affaires au
cours des prochains mois on puisse être
un peu outillés que ben peut-être
il ya beaucoup de mises en chantier au
québec à chaque année au canada à
travers à travers notre pays on rénove
beaucoup et on construit beaucoup mais
c'est ça on rénove beaucoup plus qu'on
construit du neuf ok donc beaucoup plus
de travail à faire au niveau de la
rénovation puis peut-être un des points
un des points qu'on oublie parfois
laisser notre gestion des déchets je
peux qu on fait notre cuisine ben on
prend un gros paquet déchets permet ça
dans l'eau dans nos poubelles et ses
poubelles boys ont possiblement deux
chemins ils s'en vont se faire enfouir
où ils s'en vont se faire brûler dans
les deux cas va il va y avoir soit du
co2 soit du méthane qui vote émis plus
gros danger pour notre pour notre
production de ges dont quatre ans quand
on fait nos rénovations ou quand on
pense à à changer de bâtiment ou à
construire bâtiment d'y aller avec des
choix qui vont être qu'ils vont durer
dans le temps pas forcément suivre la
dernière mode de la cuisine rouge
brillante qui te refais la mode dans
trois ans de voir m c'est d'y aller avec
des choix intelligents puis comme comme
mes collègues disait le but n'est pas
d'avoir de changer complètement notre
mode de vie de vivre dans une société
contraignant qui diront pas plus l'avion
rénove plus c'est juste de peser le pour
et le contre et de tous les gestes puis
je pense que beaucoup d'options
aujourd'hui on peut aller choisir un
matériel plus plus vert qu'un autre on
peut choisir d'acheter un produit qui
fabriqué dans la région localement
plutôt que celui qui est importé parce
qu'encore aujourd'hui on peut se faire
faire une cuisine qui est monté en plein
rush ip envoyées ici par silva lemaître
de bateaux baisse à ça s'additionne aux
pois dgs des matériaux qui ont été
extraits souvent en dehors de notre
territoire les pays où est-ce que ça a
été fait e sont électrifiées ou son
énergie utilisent des énergies fossiles
pour pour ses lectrices y est et donc
tout ça s'accumule sur nos gs c'est vrai
que moi au jour le jour j'ai jemma
cuisine puis j'ai des lumières au del
damas dans ma cuisine si j'ai fait venir
ma cuisine d'europe 1 dans mon poids de
grs mondiale binger tout le trajet que
mes matériaux en fait qui s'additionne à
mon empreinte donc penser un peu à nos
choix pour que là je reviens à l'exemple
de cuisine mais pour qu'on soit content
de cuisine pendant des années des années
qu'on n'est pas le goût de la changer
deux ans plus tard et puis et puis si on
doit absolument jeter des objets jetés
des matériaux ben le faire de façon
responsable aujourd'hui on a des centres
de tri on a des compagnies spécialisées
qui récupère des matériaux on peut
acheter les matériaux recyclés on peut
décider d'acheter des matériaux quand
contenu recyclé si on n'est pas à l'aise
avec du vieux bois on peut quand même
acheter du bois qui contient des
vieilles matière est donc juste en
faisant ces petits gestes là bas on
contribue largement
diminuer la quantité d'énergie consommée
est ce que ce sont des gestes qui coûte
nécessairement plus cher ben
habituellement la balle quand on veut
vendre notre salade c'est sûr kordic non
dans les faits les dernières
statistiques en fait que j'ai que j'ai
présentée à
les étudiants récemment c'était sur un
bâtiment leed un bâtiment leed platine
on entend ça ici c'est un bâtiment leed
entre autres
bâtiments leed coûtera environ 5 à 6 %
plus cher à fabriquer ok est-ce qu'on
rentre dans notre argent a pris un
certain nombre d'années très rapidement
ok si je vous dis quand même par exemple
vous êtes 60% plus économes en
électricité le 60% d'économie que vous
faites à chaque année massy de l'argent
que vous gardez dans vos poches si je
vous dis que les matériaux on va être
beaucoup plus durable que du plancher si
c'est un plancher par exemple comme ici
en béton je vous dis que vous êtes bon
pour 50 ans versus ce plancher flottant
en plastique
ne pas changer le plancher à chaque et
10 ans où le loup le tapis c'est encore
de l'argent qui rentre dans vos qui
reste dans vos poches donc oui oui un
petit surcoûts et des fois j que d'en
haut niveau au niveau résidentiel on
arrive à faire des bâtiments écologiques
ont zéro surcoût alors oui peut-être
mini sûr qu'au départ mais le retour sur
investissement se fait assez rapidement
j'ai plein de questions mais je vois que
quelqu'un au micro donc on va prendre
question ne sera que la pointe des
sciences montréal concernant la gestion
des dieux chaque consultant puisse m'en
chaut journal un exemple la ville
d'edmonton avec énergie et sherbrooke ou
kigali fille du che qui vont au site
d'enfouissement
pour être l'un de 180 par année 55
millions qu'a produit 38 38 millions de
lieux de tournage
parce que tu te retrouves à de 30 40
pièces de d'enfouissement pas dire des
retours sur investissement 4,5 à 6 chez
les abeilles qui investit 6 et leur
ailier acquiert des sites ou naïve
patalo capot de retour dès ce matin nos
histoires la kodak titre est contacté
de 50 milliards de subventions se base
sur des défiscalisations exonérations
taxation aux choses aux pétrolières et à
des compagnies et fameuse compagnie si
julien dray qui produit les gaz à effet
de serre sont pas prêts à baisser sens
un peu mieux sur quoi se base la nasa
s'est mis en route au point du mondial
sap à sa place on veut éliminer
on veut la fabrication de co2 puis vous
parler d'albert total à devoir réduire
les factures de pétrole
de
thar bitumineux donc les choix
politiques finalement monsieur ça fait
référence au soin à nos choix politiques
nous soit d'investissement peut-être que
monsieur lapointe sujet d'un jeu va
dépasser la question de l'alberta ted
parler de nous de la fiscalité
municipale est basé sur
la taxation foncière et la taxation
foncière nous amène comme ville fait
plus de développement
construire plus de bâtiments construire
plus de routes reconstruire en fait
faire en sorte que le développement où
l'addition des
taxes ou des revenus de taxes nous
permettent de croire d'une certaine
façon ils là c'en est un on en est à un
gala sables bitumineux de cette façon là
parce que finalement on nous force à
développer et à créer des occasions de
production de gaz à effet de serre
faudrait voir ça et ça ça fait partie
des discussions et des demandes qu'on
formule actuellement revoir leur système
fiscal et faire en sorte que les
améliorations qu'on puisse apporter à
nos systèmes à notre meilleure gestion
environnementale puisse nous amener une
certaine façon des revenus alors on
pourra peut-être faire des transferts
penser à faire des transferts que c'est
un rat des de taxation qui sont donnés à
des grandes entreprises puissent
éventuellement servir à financer un
fonctionnement municipal qui est un peu
plus écologique un peu plus respectueux
et un peu plus
réducteur de la pollution gaz à effet de
serre comme on l'est la présence joie
gazéification des déchets il ya des
projets en banlieue de montréal si je me
traîne actuellement les orientations que
ce sont polis c'est le compostage ou la
biométhanisation
on n'est pas encore passé on n'est pas
encore passée il ya des demandes sont
formulées par des grands centres urbains
pour aller jusqu'à la biométhanisation
palladio de méthanisation et les
gazéification mais on n'est pas entendu
leur camp dans le processus décisionnel
les
beaucoup à ceux ci la gazéification
pour aux anciens
non pas que ce tact mais lorsqu'on
brûler les déchets
c'est aux incinérateurs à l'air encore
on n'est pas passés à ces étapes là et
possiblement que ça pourrait être une
approche technologique qui devrait être
intéressant mais ça n'est pas pour quels
déchets ont fait si on a récupéré le
maximum du recyclage si on a fait en
sorte de récupérer la partie bio
dégradable de nos déchets qu'on l'a
acheminée vers une gestion énergétique
vers l'est et biométhane isr bat ce qui
reste possiblement pour être dirigés
vers des centres de ce type là il y a
des projets ya des orientations qui
veulent qu'on
comptait zéro déchets enfouis en l'an
2020 on a poussé je pense d'une année ou
deux cette échéance là mais on se dirige
lentement et mais sûrement vers cet
objectif là depuis avoir d'enfouissement
du pain
tout à fait
merci monsieur on a d'autres questions
venant d'internet joint oui beaucoup de
questions j'en ai une qui provient de
youtube entre autres alors nicolas
marchandises qui nous dit merci pour le
forum et qui s'adresse directement à
madame lessard dames les soeurs qui
parle du manque de liaison entre les
différents acteurs
quelles sont ses propositions afin que
tout le monde travaille ensemble
bon moi je vais parler je viens ici
rhodes le ciruit c'est un organisme
interface du milieu de la recherche avec
les acteurs de la société fait qu'on
essaie vraiment d'amener de faire cette
liaison là les organismes interface que
ça soit au milieu de la recherche ou par
exemple entre citoyens et entreprises
entre municipalités citoyens bref il y
avait plusieurs acteurs là dans le fond
on parle de la recherche le secteur
privé le secteur public le citoyen les
organisations c'est ça que moi je pense
qu'il faut insister sur 7 sur ce
fondement l'eau ce besoin là souvent
quand il ya des coupures au niveau
économique les premiers dès les
premières choses à être sabrer ccc
financement là qui assure la liaison
entre ces différents si lula et moi je
pense que il faut davantage comprendre
que tout est en place c'est que les gens
s'y par le post bac qui veulent pas ce
qu'ils se connaissent pas entre eux donc
je crois vraiment ces organisations
interface là qu'il faut leur donner
davantage de pouvoir et et même au
niveau ministériel ôter tout tous tous
et toutes des si l'on peut parler de
silos au niveau des disciplines mais
aussi au niveau des ministres qui se
parlent pas ou bien la difficulté donc
d'assurer une liaison au travers ses
différentes boîtes le moi je crois que
c'est là qu'on va innover vraiment parce
que on est en train de dilapider des
fonds publics à investir dans des choses
qui sont ailleurs puisque si on
apprenait à se connaître s'il y avait
des organisations et des agents de
liaison comme si je prêche pour ma
paroisse mais il y avait des agents de
liaison qui sont là qui sont des
interfaces des traducteurs en différents
milieux moi je pense que on gaspillerait
moins deux fois par mois vous avez la
parole oui on vient de parler
d'enfouissement des déchets avant d'en
arriver là il ya tout un cycle de vie
puisqu'elle vous vous intéressez oui et
lors d'un échange qu'on a eues par
courriel vous m'avez parlé des arbres de
noël je pense qu'on est pas mal au bon
moment pour pour en discuter
question arbres naturels ou arbre
artificiel
je sais que plusieurs d'entre vous
connaissez la proche cycle de vie
l'analyse de cycle de vie qui est un
super outil pour justement éviter de
déplacer des impacts d'un endroit à
l'autre c'est que par exemple si je
donne un exemple concret et on peut on
entend beaucoup les véhicules
électriques que c'est important bon
d'investir dans l'est parce que c'est à
l'utilisation salle à moins d'un paquet
tout et c'est vraiment quelque part mais
si on fait pas attention à tout le
processus cycle de vie c'est-à-dire de
l'extraction des matières des matières
premières jusqu'à la fin de vie on
risque d'être juste prendre des choix de
société privilégiez des des solutions
quand on se dit aussi c'est la solution
qu'il faut faire et de déplacer si je
reviens pour les véhicules électriques
oui à l'utilisation c'est moins
polluants mais il reste que la
technologie au niveau des piles
électriques elle n'est pas encore
elle n'est pas encore optimale est pire
que ça c'est qu'on utilise beaucoup les
piles au lithium et au cobalt et ça
c'est une ressource qui va être disparu
dans moins de 40 ans donc oui on peut
privilégier sa met en risque de déplacer
si on prend pas en compte tout le cycle
de vie du produit au-delà de ça aussi au
québec c'est correct de faire la
promotion des véhicules électriques
parce qu'on a le droit l'électricité
mais si on regarde par exemple dans
d'autres provinces ou si le charbon et
que l'on fait la promotion de seul le
charbon cc sig le plus polluant de tous
les
l'énergie fossile on va faire du
déplacement l'impact puis donc la
solution c'est le fameux arbre de noël
est ce qu'on prend en or ou en prend b
mais je vais vous dire ça dépend puis ça
c'est la position inconfortable de dire
ça dépend mais moi je veux savoir je
pourrais vous dire il ya eu une analyse
de cycle de vie qui s'est fait sur les
sapins de noël donc grosso modo si vous
acheter un sapin artificiel et que vous
le garder pendant vingt ans vous allez
être plus écologique que de prendre un
sapin naturel 20 ans 20 ans donc vous
devez vous poser la question à titre de
consommateur ce que vous allez garder
votre sapin de noël pendant 20 ans mais
donc c'est toujours des choix des
compromis c'est cette position l'odeur
on cherche c'est quoi la meilleure
solution mais on n'a pas de solution
plus verte c'est juste des solutions -
brume et qui vont avoir certains
compromis associés c'est un petit peu 5
confortable dans ce vieux sapins de noël
voilà vous avez parlé dans la cuisine
des lumières led ouais ou oled est ce
que justement dans un sapin de noël avec
de deux vieilles éclairage plus
énergivores par rapport aux nouvelles
c'est banal dans un sapin de noël un
mois par année on s'entend mais dans un
grand bâtiment et on pense souvent ou ou
lumière qui restent allumées dans les
édifices industriels
et on entend aussi de l'autre côté oui
mais ça génère de la chaleur il faut pas
s'en faire en faire tout un plat
l'énergie qui est dépensé en électricité
pour éclairer les édifices les chauffe
également plusieurs mois par année donc
c'est quoi le point de vue qu'un que
quelle tête on doit se faire à ce sujet
là bas
d'abord c'est vrai que lorsqu'on a
beaucoup d'éclairage qui fait de la
chaleur dans un bâtiment sas a produit
la chaleur dans le bâtiment c'est ce que
fait ou suffit casque une galerie pas du
tout aussi efficace qu'on s'entend
là-dessus ça prendrait beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'éclairage pour chauffer un
bâtiment le problème c'est que si notre
bâtiment et et pas étanchée pas isolés
mais assez de chaleur là va sortir
dehors ok alors oui on produit un peu de
chaleur mon la paire de toute façon si
on était dans un bâtiment parfait
parfaitement isolé parfaitement étanche
ou est ce qui est très peu des changes
de chaleur avec l'extérieur ben voyons
effectivement pourrait éventuellement
réduire le chauffage du bâtiment mais je
pense que la majorité des bâtiments qui
sont encore éclairé aux halles quand
dessins ne sont pas forcément très écolo
aujourd'hui est donc changer l'éclairage
dans un bâtiment comme ça est ce que
c'est ce que ça serait est-ce que ça a
un impact wii sera l'impact sur le dell
consomme 80 % moins d'énergie que
l'incandescent mais est ce que ça serait
le juste le est ce que ce serait le
premier geste affaire possiblement n'ont
donc à prendre par rapport au passé sa
pige abondant
vraiment dans le dans la direction d'un
collègue ce qui compte c'est vraiment de
voir ce globalement on achète de
l'éclairage où on achète un sapin de
noël combien de temps passez go on pense
garder ça notre sapin de noël artificiel
même s'il nous vient de la chine même si
fait en plastique puis possiblement il
sera jamais recyclés à la fin de sa vie
si on arrive à le garder assez longtemps
pour que dans la période qu'on le garde
et ben on a évité consommer peut-être
des sapins naturels ou d'autres sortes
de produits parce que je parlais de mode
de cuisine tout à l'heure et des modes
de sapins aussi le je me souviens des
les guirlandes en forme de glaçons là on
n'en voit plus de
cette année c'est l'éclairage par petits
points qui tourne il n'y est fort
probable que ça soit plus la mode
l'année prochaine donc quand on fait un
choix comme consommateurs d'acheter
quelque chose ben plus notre cycle de
vie plus on va garder notre objet
longtemps peut-être moins d'impact
hongrois mais une autre question micro
monsieur en hongrie comme métérologue
donc là dessus je vais commencer en
disant que comme métérologue qu'on parle
de solution face au climat on est déjà
15 à 20 en retard par rapport à ce qu'on
aurait dû faire donc on a traîné les
pattes on ça nous oblige à nous rabattre
à des objectifs on veut assez de
restreindre l'augmentation des
températures à 2 degrés celsius
puis encore là ça va demander de grands
changements dans nos modes de vie pour
arriver à ce don qu'il faut pas être
faut pas être pessimiste mais il ya de
grands efforts à faire dans ce cadre là
j'ai deux questions en fait pour
monsieur amadou de du groupe delà de la
ok je sais que vous faites des fêtes des
conseils auprès d'investisseurs de
portefeuille et puis gestion de risque
je lisais récemment par exemple que la
fondation des frères rockefeller a
décidé de bien qu'ils se soient enrichis
dans dans le pétrole ont décidé de
s'éloigner de tout
libéré de tout abandonner leurs
investissements dans le pétrole je veux
savoir la part de votre groupe de gens
comme vous qu'est ce que c'est une des
solutions pouvaient apporter parce qu on
sait qu encore les combustibles persie
sont subventionnés à coup de dizaines de
milliards de dollars par rapport aux
énergies renouvelables donc je le vois
ce qui doit être fait ce que vous quelle
optique vous prenez là dessus il ya
monsieur le maire ici on parlait ici au
québec qu'on a un objectif de réduction
des gaz à effet serre de 37 5% c'est un
bon chiffre on a pas de clans record ça
ça va demander des grands changements
dans la société ce que ça va être assez
pour atteindre un objectif de 2 degrés
celsius à la con a déjà des impacts sur
la météo et le climat des changements
climatiques je la vois si au niveau de
l'union des municipalités
suite à la cap 21 ou les lillois ont
entassé présent on sait que le maire de
montréal est là bas est-ce que vous au
niveau de l'union vous avez un plan pour
venir soutenir ce que le gouvernement du
québec va
la famille question doit il est à vous
je vais commencer
oui on a beaucoup dont on a beaucoup de
clients au secteur financier qui
commencent à s'intéresser à l'empreinte
carbone de leur portefeuille
d'investissements et d'actifs financiers
et récemment il ya un groupe de trente
ou trente quarante investisseurs
institutionnels donc d des entreprises
qui gèrent des fonds de retraite quoi
qui ont pris l'engagement de commencer à
calculer l'empreinte carbone de leurs
portefeuilles d'investissements ce qui a
pas été vraiment fait jusqu'à maintenant
les les les pollueurs directs font
depuis longtemps le calcul ou
l'inventaire de leurs gaz à effet de
serre les financiers n'ont pas vraiment
commencé c'est exact cela à comprendre
la manière dont ils dont ils comment
dire cantons qui la soutiennent
l'émission de gaz à effet serre au
travers de leurs investissements
financiers
et certaines de ces financière là ont
pris l'engagement également de commencer
à prendre ça en compte dans leurs
décisions de gestion de portefeuille
c'est une action concrète que certaines
sociétés ont commencé à prendre en
compte
donc c'était la com continue à être
minoritaires mais je dirais que ça
commence à prendre pas mal de 1
d'ampleur tout cas les nos clients
commencent à en parler
et je dirais qu'une autre action que
c'est financière là pourrait prendre en
pourrait mettre en oeuvre c'est de
supporter de soutenir les entreprises de
production technologies vertes et
propres dans leurs stratégies
d'investissement également ce que les
gouvernements commencent à faire au
travers d'un d'obligations vertes donc
ses actifs financiers qu'ils émettent
pour justement investir dans des
entreprises technologies propres donc il
commençait à avoir des mouvements dans
ce secteur-là secteur de la finance qui
est qui qui est un petit peu en retard
mais qui commence à être actif sur le
dossier climat
à tendre les entreprises pour avoir des
grandes ambitions pour l'environnement
si ce n'est pas rentable et on peut
comprendre évidemment la logique dans
laquelle ils travaillent donc peut-être
que c'est davantage au niveau des
gouvernements ou
nude de la gouvernance locale d'abord
dire que
oui la maire de montréal est un copte 21
mai la présidente de l'union des
municipalités mathieu anne roy et tous y
a comme 21 tous et à paris avec madame
st-hilaire de de longueuil on
s'intéresse à ces travaux là et je dois
vous dire que toute la démarche de
réduction de gaz à effet de serre à
l'union des municipalités
on y travaille depuis certainement une
dizaine d'années les actions les
changements dans les municipalités se
sont amorcées il ya déjà une dizaine
d'années à l'époque où on a commencé à
faire l'inventaire
des sources de production de gaz à effet
de serre issues des démarches municipal
du fonctionnement municipal
on a identifié les flops municipal et
les camions les voitures comme étant une
des sources importantes et déjà depuis
une dizaine d'années des actions étaient
prises dans chacune des municipalités
on peut retrouver même dans les petites
municipalités des voitures électriques
on peut retrouver des camions qui sont
approvisionnées ou alimentées au gaz
propane donc ces changements ont déjà
commencé à se faire dans chacune des
municipalités donc c'est pas d'hier
qu'on y pense deuxièmement d'autres
actions qui ont été prises la gestion
des la gestion des eaux pluviales
on a changé aussi si vous allez dans les
villes vous allez vous apercevoir que de
moins en moins il y aura des
stationnements avec des surfaces
d'asphalt sans rien y voir sans rien
voir d'arbres sans rien voir de de 10
lots de 10 lots de fraîcheur pour
contrer les îlots de chaleur des
modifications au niveau de la gestion de
nos infrastructures
c'est changer aussi on gère dont je vous
disais qu'on gère les eaux pluviales
mais finalement on s'est arrêtés depuis
plusieurs années de grossir la
tuyauterie pour éventuellement récupérer
la totalité des eaux de surface partout
et récupérer les mairies dans certains
cas aux eaux domestiques
donc là il ya des actions concrètes on
est engagé dans le processus de
recyclage d matière des matières
résiduelles on est engagés actuellement
dans le processus de collecte des débats
tiers biodégradables on s'est engagé
depuis plusieurs années je le répète
dans une démarche alors peu importe les
objectifs qui vont être fixés et peu
importe que le ce que le canada ou même
québec décidera en termes d'objectifs on
est déjà dans ce processus là et on n'a
pas pas d'atteindre ces objectifs là
parce qu'on est déjà en marche alors je
pense qu'à ce niveau là on peut se
féliciter des actions d'avoir été
prévenants et encore une fois je vous le
dis tout ce qui se décide atterri dans
les municipalités tout ce qui est toutes
ces grandes lois qui vont être passées
ces programmes qui vont être mis en
place vont atterrir chez nous on est
prêt à les recevoir et même à les
bonifier d'une certaine façon sur la
pointe le fut un temps où
l'environnement c'était pas très payant
électoralement
maintenant est-ce que seul est devenu un
peu plus bas fait les gens élisent des
personnes qui sont conscients des
problématiques et liste des personnes
qui sont porteurs de messages et ils
viennent aux séances de conseil nous
dire d'écouter
voici les choses incohérentes que vous
faites pas ce qu'on fait pas tout des
bonnes choses des choses incohérentes
que vous faites et ça ça pollue
davantage
qu'est ce que vous allez faire pour
corriger ces situations des gens sont
beaucoup plus informés ils sont beaucoup
plus éduqués aujourd'hui et sont
conscients de ouvre la planète
actuellement que vous voit nos milieux
de vie dans le contexte oui c'est un
sujet qui
général le sujet le plus important d'une
campagne électorale où naît le savoir si
on sauve la planète si on est en train
de sauver notre ville du sud on est en
train de périr donc le niveau municipal
serait peut-être avant gardiste par
rapport au provincial et au fédéral où
on a vu encore récemment que
l'environnement n'est pas nécessairement
l'enjeu le plus le plus abordé
évidemment ça dépend toujours de ou
hendaye âge qui a fait c'est d'ailleurs
ce qui a fait que
moi j'estime qu'on est en avance
surtout ces programmations là il sur
toutes les décisions gouvernementales
on ne trie taureau par les cornes parce
que ça l'est un impact aussi ne pas
s'occuper des déchets
ça fait en sorte on se retrouve avec des
quantités phénoménales de déchets au pas
alors les gens sont conscients sur le
plan visuel sur le plan de la gestion au
6e ip la taxe
annuelle qui est associé à soi puisque
ce soit face et pas de la voir grandir
il souhaite que nos actions nous
permettent de stabiliser cette taxation
leur hymen l'arrêt du
joueur oui alors sur notre notre forum
entrer quelqu'un qui nous demande je
vous amène sur un autre chemin
totalement et qui nous parle de la
france qui présente dans ces lois sur la
transition énergétique qui a été adoptée
par le parlement en juillet
l'obsolescence programmée qui devient
une infraction punie de deux ans prison
et de trois cent mille euros d'amendé
alors pourquoi ne pas faire la même
chose au québec et au canada alors
est-ce que également jeu pour élargir
est ce que c'est un mythe l'offre
essence programmés ou
c'est un fait madame les crois que je
peux aider un petit peu pour ça j'ai
suivi un cours la session dernière au
printemps dernier avec fabien durif qui
est responsable de l'observatoire
consommation responsable c'est un nos
collaborateurs aussi rhodes
premièrement l'obsolescence programmée
ça serait un mythe c'est à dire qu'on va
parler d'une obsolescence relative parce
que programmer implique un espèce
d'esprit machiavélique derrière les
choses puis que tout d'un coup mon
ordinateur il
ya un fil et ça a explosé c'est la fin
c'est programmé un telle date tel mais
ça c'est pas vrai c'est pas comme ça que
ça fonctionne par contre oui il ya une
espèce de culture de l'obsolescence
relative qui est de concevoir des
produits qui sont de moins en moins
performants ou de moins en moins durable
c'est à dire que souvent il va avoir une
pièce qui va qui vont être mous depuis
pas de pièces mais de moindre qualité
puis c'est bien connu des
électroménagers les gros électro les
frigos et où là c'est une durée de vie
de 8 à 10 ans oui faudrait que ça c'est
une grosse problématique et c'est
d'ailleurs
dans le milieu de la recherche on
s'intéresse de plus en plus à ce
phénomène là parce que ça n'a jamais été
prouvée le clip this vraiment une
obsolescence programmée comme juste une
obsolescence relative qui est en place
il ya énormément de choses à regarder
justement dans le monde pour essayer de
prendre des exemples je pense que des
fois au lieu de réinventer la roue ben
on regarde ce qui se passe ailleurs on
voit c'est quoi les facteurs de succès
et les choses à éviter qu'ils n'ont pas
bien marché puisque de rapporter ça donc
je suppose et ça répond en partie à la
question oui est ce qu'on ne va pas
aussi des comportements par exemple
est-ce que les gens pourraient faire un
effort davantage pour faire réparer des
choses c'est ça c'est la culture en fait
on peut s'en aller vers un autre géant
ne la culture de l'efficience on dit
qu'il faut être plus performant on va
avoir des projets des produits plus
technologiques qui vont être mieux
conçus et tout et tout mais il ya la
notion aussi de suffisance qu on oublie
qu'on oublie bien souvent et cette
surconsommation la l'obsolescence
programmée bien aussi ouvre la ti vient
aussi de ce cette surconsommation là en
fait c'est que c'est comme ça on décide
de s'attaquer au problème via on va
concevoir des produits durablement mais
d'un autre côté on a de la difficulté à
avoir un regard sur notre consommation
qu'on on le sait on surconsomme pas
qu'il ya des questions des débats
philosophiques de sociétés à se poser
davantage croix pour parce qu'en parlant
on va dire qu'on va régler le problème
comme ceux ci ont trempé temps de
comprendre pourquoi on surconsomme
pourquoi cette notion de suffisance là
elle fait pas partie de notre façon
d'évoluer je pense qu'on va passer à
côté de quelque chose et en 2015 du sel
d'acheter l'appareil ménager qu'ils
étaient construits dans les années 80 et
qui tuerait 35 ans donc on est produit
actuellement la réparation c'est qu'on
n'est pas non plus dans la culture de la
réparation c'est comme soi que j'achète
j'ai fait réparer mon frigo ça va me
coûter 300 de l'argent n'achète pas un
usage et ça va me coûter 200 $ il ya
quelque chose qui est un non sens et que
les gens disposent c'qui à toute une
culture à revoir là dessus je suis
amadou est ce que vous sentez que les
entreprises ont
une volonté de changer et peut-être de
de
faire de la promotion davantage à propos
de leurs produits qui duraient plus
longtemps est ce que ça fait partie de
la culture d'entreprise que de vouloir
amener mon demeurer compétitifs mais en
s'amenant sur le terrain de l'écologie
clairement plus on vend de produits plus
on fait de profits ça c'est assez clair
je pense oui il n'y a pas moyen d'en
vendre - plus cher dans une logique de
développement durable et d'être
justement au goût du jour et attrayant
pour un consommateur lorsqu'on on fait
de mise en marché où on dit que le
produit est un moins énergivore c'est
une chose pour la facture d'électricité
lorsqu'on est qu'il va durer plus
longtemps à quel point on est rendu là
par rapport à ce qui est un spécial bon
marché et qu'on peut se procurer tout de
suite ici mais je peux pas dire que j'ai
des exemples concrets en tête
d'entreprises qui ont mis en place une
démarche de produits durables de
produits à longue longévité ceci dit la
plupart des entreprises au niveau
provincial sont soumises à des
obligations des taxes en matière de deux
qui sont basés sur la génération de
déchets donc sur le sur la quantité de
déchets qu'ils produisent et aussi au
niveau des électroménagers ils ont une
obligation de recycler 6 électroménager
l'a donc en pratique je sais pas si un
set ce recyclage des déchets vraiment et
efficace mais ces réglementations
existent mais effectivement il ya tout
un effort à faire au niveau de la
commercialisation et du rebranding de
ces produits là qu'ils sont sont pas
forcément efficace à court terme mais
qui sont durables dans lé pouvoir porter
le message mais oui après quand vous
sortez du si vous avez avec
moi je voulais juste
parce qu'on parle des compagnies tout ça
mais moi je suis persuadé je suis
convaincu que le pouvoir est aux
consommateurs ok les compagnies
innovantes ce qu'on leur demande si on
reprend le vote exemple de l'aveu suta
la plus ça va plus les aveux sont
grosses et belles
je pense avoir marqué comme les
carrosseries de l'aveu s'est rendu ses
rangs du bo il ya de l'effort qui est
mis là dessus marc contre l'intérieur on
s'y intéresse pas les gens veulent
quelque chose de beau et veulent montrer
leur laveuse
quelqu'un qui commercialiserait
aujourd'hui une laveuse des années 80
fait comme un tank mais qui va durer
vingt ans peut-être qu'ils
rencontreraient pas tout de suite un
grand succès mais si c'est les six les
consommateurs qui vont vers ces produits
si les consommateurs disent moi je suis
prêt j'ai fait mon calcul je prêt à
payer un peu plus cher aujourd'hui et pu
m'en soucier pendant un temps plutôt que
de le dire bah chaque fois à chaque 5 1
je vais devoir me pose la question est
ce que je fait réparer ou est ce que je
fais pas réparer puis après deux
réparations je vais me dire aux robes à
loches sont rendus au prix du neuf je
pense que le consommateur beaucoup
beaucoup de pouvoir puis ça c'est pas
juste dans les électroménagers je pense
est dans tout que ce soit dans l'énergie
que les matériaux ou les solutions
transport france qu'est le consommateur
va créer la vo créer l'offre la demande
va créer l'offre puis à nous comme
consommateur d'exiger des produits qui
durent plus longtemps pour finalement en
obtenir parce que les compagnies vont
continuer de faire des profits à
condition de nous vendre des produits si
on arrête d'acheter les laveuses qui
lâche après cinq ans bien vendre aux
puits en ferons plus donc le voisin
gonflables je pense vraiment avec la
laveuse qu'il doit se faire valoir
auprès des autres on peut avoir la vue
un peu moins belle de l'extérieur un peu
plus efficace de l'intérieur la garder
plus longtemps effectivement c'est bon
c'est ça le chargement sacha ces
changements de mentalité chine où vous
allez voir toutes les lettres
écoutez l'aide
l'éclairage est loin de là mais ce que
je veux dire ce changement de mentalité
on est habitué de dire j'ai acheté un
téléviseur il fait 46 pouces dans trois
ans ce programme y est mort parce que
pour le prix que j'ai payé je peux y
avoir maintenant 65 pouces on est
habitué à changer sondes on devrait
avoir plus
notre conscience devraient nani plus
vers la la fierté d'avoir un objet qui
perdure un objet qui réparable d'un
objet qui peut évoluer plutôt qu'un
objectif facilement rappela ça peut-être
un retour de balancier
alors sur youtube il ya un reynald web
qui nous pose une question qui
consomment plus le monde municipal alors
comment et avec quels moyens la ville de
victoriaville au québec at elle réussi à
prendre le cap vert et non d'autres
villes alors est ce que je sais pas si
vous avez des exemples concrets sur ce
que victoriaville fr puis comment on
finance finalement ces mesures là pour
être
pour le victoriaville ils ont une
association avec une eau bnl et avec une
entreprise privée en fait ils ont fait
du recyclage
leur spécialité en faire ça existe toute
cette opération ne s'est pas amorcé dans
dans les dernières années ça fait au
moins 25 30 ans qui ils injectent des
jeunes
écologique à leur population mais aussi
qu'ils font en sorte de développer une
industrie est véritablement une
industrie du recyclage ils ont fait en
sorte de même d'en arriver à développer
de nouveaux produits avec des résidus
tout récemment il ya une semaine ils ont
reçu un pliant viejo lice pour avoir
fait en sorte de développer
de développer des briques des briques de
pavage qu'il fabrique à partir de
plastique recyclé
de ciment et d'un mélange en fait ils
ont fait totalement le cycle art
ils en arrivent à produire quelque chose
qui va être un produit de consommation
qui pourrait être utilisé à des fins
domestiques dans les entrées de
les entrées de garage des entrées de
maisons et poussent donc en fait ils ont
développé de la recherche ils ont à
partir des produits qui est récupérée
chercher à faire mieux et a fermé hier
mais est retourné aux domestiques ce qui
était ce qui provient du domestique à
larissa ils ont développé cette
industrie l'appui sont un peu des
modèles pour d'autres d'autres
municipalités qui développe actuellement
de nouvelles technologies on a des
exemples on a dans le transport
collectif la ville de québec en oeuvre
cette île qui est en train de
gérer ou d'approcher
une nouvelle façon de terre puisqu'ils
ont des problèmes d'érosion
en
bordure du
de l'océan de l'atlantique alors
évidemment eux ils doivent corriger donc
ils doivent un timbre en tiff à celle du
voleur meilleur garant de better
municipalité il y a lieu de
biométhanisation de viette du loup il y
à saint-hyacinthe qui a produit va
produire en fait d'ailleurs commençait
même à produire des du gaz méthane à
partir de la biométhanisation
à la fois de
biodégradables des matières
biodégradables domestique mais dégrade a
décidé institutions des commerces et des
industries donc à quelque part il y en a
des exemples à donner au québec deux
municipalités qui ont pris des
initiatives qui à partir d'un problème
qu'ils avaient à leur régime les ont
trouvé des façons de faire qui les amène
à avoir une pratique beaucoup plus
écologique à être des modèles pour
d'autres municipalités alors si on
faisait l'inventaire de toutes les
municipalités de plusieurs municipalités
et la regarder petit on retrouve des
pratiques un peu partout qu'on s'échange
ça c'est de la vente âge d'être associé
à l'union des municipalités du québec ou
à la fédération québécoise des
municipalités à chaque année on se
retrouve ensemble pour échanger sur nos
pratiques et voir quel état sont à
adapter les meilleures pratiques à nos
façons de vivre nos façons de gérer nos
municipalités les sons
et visites soit fond
aux dirigeants de saint-hyacinthe il
reçoit convient de les idées des autres
municipalités pour voir de quelle façon
ils vont adapter leur
leur façon de faire comment on peut
gérer de la même façon vous encore avec
des variantes comment on peut adapter sa
nou façon de procéder la même chose se
produit à victoriaville c'est des gens
qui invite les eaux
l'avantagé que c'est gratuit en
municipalité on n'a pas à dépenser mais
ces gens là ont développé des expertises
qu'il
partage avec d'autres et c'est ça qui
nous fait certainement avancer beaucoup
plus vite les modèles les municipalités
deviennent des modèles pour les autres
et on trouve on tourne notre camp
des élus ou des dirigeants que ce soit
on et municipalités ou des eaux dans le
milieu corporatif éclairé des gens qui
ont envie de faire bouger les choses au
delà des incitatifs ou ou de la demande
des consommateurs ou des actionnaires
c'est pour ça que nous on passe pas mal
de temps à discuter avec des ciseaux
avec des présidents de sociétés pour
essayer de leur faire comprendre
les opportunités d'affaires qui ont
trait au développement durable ou la
gestion du changement climatique et les
risques potentiels pour une compagnie de
ne pas apprendre action à dessus aux
mêmes questions du public oui donc
bonjour je m'appelle dominique
visionnant je suis employé de la
commission scolaire marguerite bourgeoys
en fait j'arrive tout juste depuis
quelques heures de paris en fait où
j'étais avec des élèves à la conférence
des jeunes de paris peut-être que les
adultes ne savent pas mais aussi un
événement jeunesse qui se passe en même
temps que la conférence où les jeunes
peuvent s'exprimer dans neuf villes de
la planète savait lui la semaine passée
du 26 au 28 et j'avais envie aujourd'hui
de vous faire porte parole un peu de ces
jeunes là parce qu'évidemment c'est eux
qui vont vivre avec le fardeau des
décisions des non décisions
d'aujourd'hui et les jeunes mes élèves
que j'ai accompli la bande la chance et
le privilège de rencontrer le premier
ministre il ya exactement 24 heures à
peine et ils ont fait trois demandes et
je vous aiderai c'est de ces demandes là
en fait parce que aujourd'hui le thème
ses solutions pour le climat mais donc
j'adresse un souhait que je réitère au
nom des élèves les élèves ont demandé
notamment à l'intégration d'un cours
relatifs à l'éducation à l'environnement
au développement durable et au
changement climatique
évidemment on en entend parler partout
mais c'est pas quelque chose qui est
intégré dans le curriculum de cours au
quotidien du primaire au secondaire la
deuxième des choses qui ont été demandés
par les élèves s'étaient notamment
d'avoir une reprennent une
reconnaissance de l'implication des
élèves qui s'impliquent beaucoup et
activement dans nos écoles pour faire
changer les choses dans leur école et
souvent malheureusement ils ont
l'impression que les quelques rares
individus qui sont là pour les soutenir
je vous donne un exemple on est implanté
un composteur industriel dans une de nos
écoles on en implantant un deuxième
prochainement ont réduit de 75% notre
empreinte écologique par un composteur
comme celui là mais malheureusement les
subventions l'aide gouvernementale pour
l'achat de ces outils là qui nous
permettent d'agir concrètement avec des
citoyens en devenir sont souvent absents
donc on gagne à des portes les élèves
demandent des choses est souvent n'est
pas capable de les appuyer dans sa donc
s'apprendre cohérence en ce sens là et
je termine rapidement la troisième chose
qui était demandé par nos élèves au
premier ministre c'était une école qui
est cohérente avec les défis
d'aujourd'hui donc cette école là ne
devrait-elle pas être bâti de manière à
ce que l'on souhaite lancé comme message
à nos enfants nos enfants sont des fois
dans des bâtiments qui sont absolument
désuet qui n'ont aucune prouesse
environnemental on était à paris la
semaine passée a visité le collège
international noisy le grand qui est une
école qui produit son énergie qui
redonne de l'énergie aux écoles des
alentours comment se fait-il qu au
québec on n'a pas une politique
justement au niveau de l'éducation
nationale pour faire en sorte que nos
écoles soient cohérentes et quelle forme
ces jeunes citoyens là à devenir demain
aux acteurs de demain
fait intéressant tout ça
ça m'amène à penser évidemment vous
parlez de tolède d'un to global en faut
passer des choses globalement une école
qui se fait rénover même sur notre les
technologies vertes à l'intérieur encore
faut-il l'opérer de fassions de façon
verte quelque part les lic qu'on pense
aux cafétérias ou compense même pas quel
endroit où il ya des beaucoup de bons de
styromousse dans certains cas où
d'assiette et de verres jetables
encore pas mal de travail à faire
probablement que chacun de vous dans
votre vie personnelle autour de vous
nous avez des exemples où on utilise
encore la bouteille d'eau sur lors d'une
conférence où on pollue davantage est ce
que vous sentez quand même que
une certaine volonté d'aller plus loin
que par le passé dans vos milieux c'est
sûr que là je prêche peut-être dès que
je pose la question des convertis mais
quand même
oui tout à fait d'abord je voudrais
juste dire que je trouve c'est
exceptionnel d'avoir d'avoir pris le
temps l'énergie l'argent d'amener tous
ces enfants là à coke 21 bravo moi je
suis depuis toujours
convaincu qu' une grande part de la
solution c'est l'éducation ok c'est le
gros bon sens l'environnement faire
attention à nos trop faire attention
notre énergie c'est le gros bon sens
mais si on n'est pas au courant de ces
choses là bas est possible qu'on pose un
compose pour les pongistes de montrer à
nos enfants à bien se comporter à
respecter les ressources à consommer de
façon intelligente mais je pense que ces
gars en d'avenir ça ça vaut faire durer
les actions qu'on va prendre aujourd'hui
dans les écoles c'est effectivement j'ai
deux jeunes enfants puis il passe
beaucoup pensent probablement plus de
temps dans leur école qu à la maison
alors si l'école ne montre pas l'exemple
si effectivement la cafétéria on a des
bouteilles d'eau parce qu'on veut pas
s'équiper ou on veut pas avoir une
laveuse industriels pour laver des
gobelets si si on fait pas attention aux
lumières si on laisse les portes les
fenêtres ouvertes est ce que vraiment
transmet un bon message aux enfants je
pense je pense pas donc oui
effectivement faudrait que toutes les
écoles concret ou qu'on rénove
aujourd'hui soit le plus écologique
possible mon le yoyo l'aspect il ya
l'aspect financier qu'ils entrent en
ligne de compte on sait que c'est pas
facile
la question la question qui tue c'est ce
qu'ont ce qu'on investit dans
l'infrastructure ont investi dans les
gens je pense qu'il faut il faut faire
tout ça à la fois mais l'idée d'avoir un
cours d'avoir au moins des notions
qu'ils soient transmises à nos enfants
au niveau du développement durable de de
l'approché écologique je crois que ça
c'est quelque chose qui pourrait être
mise en place assez facilement on ne
plaint d'experts au québec on a plein de
personnes qui sont capables de
transmettre le message puis on a plein
d'enfants qui sont avides d'apprendre
ces messages là qui vont les transporter
chez eux et qu'ils vont dire à leurs
parents papanou à l'école on fait du
compost les choeurs de pommes on les
jette jamais dans la poubelle on les met
dans le composteur parce qu'avec ça on
peut faire de l'engrais puis avec ça on
peut faire pousser les plantes alors
transporté 6 notion l'a apprise à
l'école à la maison mais ça va faire en
sorte que peut-être des parents d'une
autre génération vont être influencés
par leurs enfants puis éventuellement
c'est pour le mieux tout le monde savait
dans la même direction on m'a dit
récemment la maison que je devais mettre
moins de pression lorsque je voudrais le
robinet pour les poissons donc après
avoir fermé le robinet quand j'étais
jeune pour se brosser les dents
maintenant on états unis une coche plus
loin si on veut de d'atténuer un peu
encore davantage notre eau donc
évidemment les messages circulent dans
différents milieux le manceau sans
garderie mais on comprend que plus vieux
il ya pris un autre chose madame lessard
vous vouliez réagir le tri g oui
j'aimerais ça réagir par rapport à ça
pour plusieurs et comme trois points que
je me lève un
des premiers points c'est l'éducation
l'environnement complètement
par contre il ya un élément intéressant
que j'ai entendu récemment qui m'a
vraiment
changé un peu ma façon de voir les
choses oui l'éducation il faut vraiment
insister puis enseigner le développement
durable dès le jeune âge mais par contre
faut pas penser non plus que cela c'est
suffisant parce que le cerveau humain
est malléable jusqu'à plus ou moins 25
ans que ça veut dire c'est qu'on n'est
pas encore notre personnalité nos
valeurs c'est encore to forget jusqu'à +
25 ans plus ou moins quelques années et
ça j'ai trouvé ça intéressant parce que
je me suis dit ok donc pour je peux
juste misé sur elle à l'éducation des
enfants faut aussi faire perdurer sa
salade doublement
des répercussions de faire sucer si tu
fais d'enseignements sur les enfants les
enfants rapporte eu à leurs parents
après donc la llo comme une
pérennisation qui peut s'instaurer mais
je pense que c'est aussi comme faut
juste faire attention de faire perdurer
sa parce que sinon je pense que si on
focalise seulement sur les enfants
risquent de manquer quelque chose qu'on
n'a pas compris au niveau biologique au
niveau cognitif l'autre chose que je
voulais dire par rapport à l'éducation à
l'environnement relative à
l'environnement un secteur primaire
secondaire
on privilégie beaucoup en ce moment les
sciences dures dans les sciences
l'ingénierie la médecine bon et c'est
correct c'est bien mais de notre côté on
est en train de sabrer complètement tous
qui sciences sociales lille ça amène un
paquet de défi parce que moi je suis
ingénieur de formation donc j'ai étudié
l'ingénierie niveau technologique on
peut développer des super system
messieurs on amène pas aussi l'aspect
social l'appropriation est-ce qu'on va
être capable d'implanter cette
technologie la presse qu'elle va être
acceptée ou non accepter social il ya
tout un élagage qu'on a fait au niveau
des sciences sociales humaines la
philosophie des trucs de base qui sont
enseignés au sujet mais qui sont
enseignées d'une façon qui rend pas très
attrayant ça dépend beaucoup du
professeur ça c'est comme le plaidoyer
pour ramener les sciences sociales qui
sont autant de plus en plus exclus et
j'avais un troisième point mais je me
rappelle que j'ai pris assez de temps
monsieur je pense que vous avez des
oreilles très ouverte ici aujourd'hui
pour les initiatives des jeunes johan
d'autres questions oui quelqu'un qui
nous parle de la consommation de viande
olivier du lieu de questions qui nous
provient commentaires en fait qu'il
provient de sites web de radio-canada
alors qui dit qu'une majeure partie des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
provient de notre consommation de viande
cette situation qui fait dire à certains
que vegan qui conduit aux moeurs serait
moins polluant que mangeurs de viande
contre les entreprises us étant son
commentaire mais bref et si on se
concentre sur notre consommation de
choix alimentaires et en quelle matière
est ce qu'on peut concrètement agir
contre les changements climatiques
c'est un gros dossier
le changement des habitudes alimentaires
pour réduire les gaz à effet de serre
mais effectivement le secteur de
l'agriculture est une grosse source
d'opportunités pour réduire les gaz à
effet de serre maintenant et aussi des
comment dire des enjeux et des limites
parce que c'est difficile de calculer
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
provenant de l'agriculture il s'agit
d'une source diffuse donc concrètement
les gaz un fait ça sort pas une cheminée
il sort d'un champ ou d'une étendue quoi
assez large mais quand même là nous des
vaches là et fao l'organisation des
nations unies sur l'alimentation et
l'agriculture
disait que le secteur bovin serez
responsable de 14,5 pour cent des
émissions mondiales donc par rapport à
l'alimentation ce qui est quand même
important bond ce pourcentage qui on
pourrait débattre effectivement les
émissions ne se font pas d'une cheminée
mais même celle d'une cheminée
semble-t-il selon les dernières études
que c'est pas aussi évident de savoir où
ou en fait quelle est la quantité
précise d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre mets donc pour dire que oui
effectivement il ya quand même une masse
critique là qui sort des du secteur
bovin notamment il ya peu de politiques
ou de dirigeants qui jusqu'à maintenant
se sont engagés sur ce terrain là
concrètement on est tous très attachés à
nos seins traditions alimentaires pas
forcément prêts à l'échanger mais
maintenant c'est vrai qu'il ya des
opportunités de réduction de gaz à effet
de serre en consommant peu plus de
légumes et de grains que de que de
viande et sans changer nécessairement
radicalement pour le consommateur on
veut pas nécessairement revenir à
l'époque où on avait des tomates
seulement l'été peut-être que certains
voudront le faire mais en émettant
l'hypothèse que tout le monde ne fera
pas ça du jour au lendemain mais quand
même des choses qu'on peut faire et
justement par rapport à notre
consommation responsable dans
l'alimentation il ya eu toute une
promotion de l'agriculture au niveau
local qui s'est développé au cours des
dernières années et maintenant les
comment les consommateurs commencent à
se poser la question entre la tomate qui
arrive de l'autre bout de la planète ou
à peu près et c'est le produite dans une
serre au québec qu'est ce qui est le
mieux finalement
pas de solution plus verte et c'était
juste des solutions - brune c'est parce
qu'en fait peur on peut pas dire 'est-ce
qu'on privilégie le local où le
biologique dans le détail on privilégie
les deux pions mais mon mail équitable
au milieu de ce hockey mais il arrive
toujours un choix même - là qui va au
supermarché où j'ai un compromis un
choix de valeurs à faire est ce que je
vois justement privilégier
l'environnement d'inhumer gaz à effet de
serre à acheter local où est ce que je
vais choisir biologique et privilégier
ma valeur sur ma santé parce que je sais
qu'il ya pas de pesticides sas et puis
un arbre il y en aura pas de bonnes il
ya le portefeuille aussi et ça c'est
quelque chose de très intéressant c'est
que
biologique et tout les systèmes
alimentaires il faut qu'ils versent ifo
qui
commande et moins bradé bruni bruni
merci
et ça c'est génial plein de belles
initiatives à montréal en région je
connais moins mère montréal avec les
fruits si avec des marchés de quartier
il ya plein de choses levitte quartier
qui prennent les les paniers bio que ça
aussi c'est à l'extérieur de montréal
c'est génial mais d'un autre côté faut
juste faire attention c'est à ce choix
de société là parce que c'est la classe
aisée la classe riche qui peut souvent
ce père médecin et quelque part on est
tous est en train de créer des déserts
et d insécurité alimentaire et de créer
l'écart encore plus grand pour les
populations vulnérables c'est quelque
chose qu'on n'oublie un petit peu
souvent parce qu'on est des gens engagés
ou qui s'intéressent à la question mais
il ya tout un autre enjeu pans de la
société qu'il faut faire attention dans
cette école qui est de plus en plus
grand
parce que manger bio pour l'instant ça
coûte plus cher quand même les enjeux du
monde agricole dans le
remontons d'un remontant dans le temps
on se posait pas ces questions là parce
qu'on ne savait pas qu'il y avait
production de gaz à effet de serre qui
origine et des pratiques des pratiques
agricoles depuis qu'on en parle ben il
ya d'autres approches sur la gestion des
déchets fumier qui se sont mises en
place
au niveau des viandes la production des
viandes maintenant les boues
qui sont produites les eaux usées qui
sont produites sont maintenant traités
ce qu'on n'avait pas antérieurement puis
les bouts de traitement sont dirigés
vers des stations de traitement pour
deviser et dans beaucoup de cas on s'en
sert pour faire aussi comme matière
générant des des
biomasses c'est à dire pour se parfaire
des dégâts sphère du méthane qui vont
servir à produire de l'énergie
l'étatique ont
nécessairement changer puis à regarder
ce qu'on est en train d'introduire toute
la gestion des matières biodégradables
domestique maintenant ça veut dire que
si on parle de cycle de vie on est en
train de changer lentement mais sûrement
les pratiques et de quelle façon on doit
consommer de quelle façon doit disposer
des produits résiduels de cette
consommation là mais la même sûrement
mesure qu'on découvre l'ampleur de la
problématique
je pense que l'intelligence qu'on a
c'est de développer des approches
technologiques qui vont nous ramener un
certain équilibre là dessus
évidemment si on pouvait revenir à la
base antérieur de la terre ce sera
merveilleux mais je pense qu'on a avec
le temps avance et il ya eu un
raffinement que ces faits au niveau de
la production alimentaire puis on doit
vivre avec ça je me préoccupe aurait
peut-être
fait que les barquettes dans lequel on
retrouve de la viande sont pas
recyclables
que tous ces produits d'emballage qui
gravitent autour des produits de
consommation il y en a beaucoup qui sont
pas recyclables et comment on pourrait
déjà corrigé cet élément la sara
entrerait dans le cycle de vie des
produits dans notre cycle de vie de
consommateurs comme tel et moi je pense
qu'il faut aussi se diriger vers eux
dans les ports a rendu à se pendre au
bout d'un homme encore là il faut pas
nécessairement s'empêcher de vie il faut
simplement arriver à changer nos
pratiques courantes nos pratiques de
notre gestion domestique et être gérée
intelligemment
je confie finalement en une question
micro simplement rappeler aux gens qui
nous regardent sur internet que nous
sommes en direct en direct de la maison
du développement durable à montréal et
jusqu'à environ 13h45 comprend les
questions du public dans la petite
fenêtre de clavardage que vous avez à
côté de votre fenêtre de webdiffusion
alors ne vous gênez pas de nous écrire
johan prend vos questions et vos
commentaires nous les rayons à nos
quatre invités et pour l'heure on prend
deux questions de monsieur ici au micro
et éric ferland projet écosphère
j'aimerais qu'on revienne un peu aussi
sur l'aspect d'agriculture biologique il
faut pas oublier aussi que l'agriculture
traditionnelle
à des gros impacts environnementaux
aussi la pollution des cours d'eau c'est
des engrais chimiques produits à partir
de pétrole etc la nuit sans souci auprès
des abeilles est un facteur économique
important aussi
c'est pas normal qu'au québec à l'heure
actuelle que les agriculteurs bio
doivent payer pour ne pas mettre des
produits chimiques dans leur
alimentation pourquoi doivent payer plus
cher pour nous promettant certains
produits faut penser à soi il faut
penser que le gouvernement doit
s'investir plus ou si il vient de passer
une loi dernier marc interdisant les
pesticides qui nuisent aux abeilles etc
bravo belle initiative mais au niveau de
l'habitation aussi la construction
écologique on pense que le code du
bâtiment r 20 c'est pas suffisant québec
non plus nous maison québec devraient
être isolés à 40 avec des toitures r60
l'efficacité énergétique dans les années
90 on en parlait beaucoup on dirait
qu'on en parle moins
tourné dans ces années là qu'un dollar
économisé a investi dans l'efficacité
énergétique et un plusieurs dollar
économisé pour les générations futures
même le fmi dernièrement vient de dire
qu'un dollar investi en environnement et
4 dollars économisés pour les
générations futures se démonter
importance et des sommes importantes
qu'on oublie
je me suis aussi de l'exemple des voix
l'arrêt dans les années soixante dix le
secteur des véhicules automobiles parce
que les compagnies américaines
construire des véhicules moins de bonne
qualité autrement dit il ya un
gouvernement mais il leur a dit non vous
allez construire des bons véhicules qui
polluent moins et c'est ce que le
gouvernement doit s'investir plus pour
que les véhicules les prochains
véhicules qui vont être mis sur le
marché produit beaucoup moins aussi
est-ce qu'il faut que la voiture à
essence soit beaucoup plus plate à
conduire autrement dit moins performante
pas fort menthe pour dégager moins de
gaz à effet de serre
du bâtiment sur fait l'analogie avec ce
que vous avez dit juste à la fin de
votre intervention une voiture plate
mais écolo je pense qu'aujourd'hui on à
la technologie en tout cas en ce qui a
trait aux bâtiments de faire des
bâtiments extrêmement confortable
extrêmement performant est tout à fait
écologique c'est ce que vous avez nommés
le code du bâtiment vient il vient
d'être révisé ce qu'on a fait ce qu'on
incorporer les notions de nouveau climat
qui nous date de près de 20 ans
j'ai vu une conférence ou est-ce que la
schl déclaré qu'ils attendaient que tout
le monde le fasse pour le mettre dans le
code je pense qu'on devrait vraiment
prendre les choses à l'envers et est
monté la barre pour obliger l'industrie
et les gens à assas conformer à des à
des méthodologies plus verte ou à des
méthodologies plus en plus efficace
aujourd'hui le code est révisée on est à
r 20
anciennement on était r14 on veut dire
on a fait un pro guerre ne peut être
augmenté de 20 % notre efficacité
énergétique mais aujourd'hui l'an 2015
on est capable de faire des maisons
qu'ils ne consomment pas de chauffage ok
tellement bien conçu tellement bien
isolés qui ont 9 0 demande de chauffage
alors est-ce que 20% c'est trop peu bien
sûr que c'est trop peu
facteur
moi c'est mon cas de fouille ouais le
facteur d'isolation des murs on est
capable de faire on a des nouveaux
matériaux on a des matériaux propres on
a des matériaux locaux on a des
matériaux fabriqués ici même au québec
on est capable de faire des maisons
extrêmement efficace par contre
aujourd'hui c'est encore très très petit
nombre de personnes qui construisent
comme ça parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'incitatifs à le faire les subventions
on passablement disparu avec le temps
les connaissances sont pas très bien
transmises non plus et le code du
bâtiment nous oblige pas à faire quelque
chose de très très efficace sans vie en
transmettre nous aujourd'hui quelques
connaissances on est dans la maison du
développement durable vous la connaissez
bien deux trois éléments qui serait
particulièrement intéressant je vois le
les plantes qui grimpe jusqu'au plafond
ici tout à l'heure on est allés visiter
le toit vert qui est plus rougeâtre que
l'arrêt ce temps ci de l'année mais
enfin un toit qui est fort intéressant
également on envisage peut-être même une
éolienne de ce que je comprends il y
avait un bon des tests qui était fait
mais tout ça pour dire que concrètement
le qu'est ce qui pourrait donner envie à
quelqu'un qui est des rénovations de
dire bon bain voici évidemment on est au
niveau industriel mais quand même qu
est-ce qui est qu'est ce qui est
particulièrement intéressant de tous
niveaux au point de vue du bâtiment by
les aspects d'efficacité énergétique
malheureusement c'est souvent cachés
dans les murs c'est parce qu'il sait pas
ce qui est glamour c'est parce qu'il
montre et vous avez parlé du mur végétal
ce mur végétal la helaba pour pour deux
raisons c'est très joli ok en fait trois
ça absorbe le son nez dans un atrium ça
pourrait ça pourrait réverbérée beaucoup
leucate parle donc ça absorbe une partie
du son et il ya un système d'air un
système de ventilation du bâtiment qui
passe à travers ce mur là donc une
purification de l'air qui se fait
derrière ce mur sans qu'on le sache il
ya aussi delaune où on l'entend je passe
où l'on attendait à la scène on entend
de l'eau qui coule c'est un rôle
d'humidification sécly vers l'air froid
extérieur rentre à l'intérieur c'est
très sec on allait on a l'habitude de
vouloir mettre des déshumidificateurs
pendant 1 pendant l'hiver çà çà çà çà ce
rôle
reviens
généré white que généralement on prend
de l'air de l'extérieur
je parle en général le même peuple
whissell général conclut pur que qu'à
l'intérieur parce qu'on est au
centre-ville de montréal normand parce
que c'est un très bon système tout à
fait et puis on parle de on parle d'un
bâtiment comme celui ci est extrêmement
étanche et extrêmement bien isolé ce qui
fait que avec les usagers à l'intérieur
on l'air qu'on respire et qu'on rejette
le co2 qu'on rejette restent enfermés à
l'intérieur du bâtiment donc le système
de ventilation très très très efficace
qui sort des grandes quantités d'air de
l'intérieur vers l'extérieur et on est
on est des technologies aujourd'hui qui
nous permettent de dire leurs consoeurs
dehors qu'on a chauffé on va le
remplacer par de l'air qui nous vient de
l'extérieur qui est froid par exemple en
hiver s'il fait moins 20 dehors puis je
me débarrasse de l'ère kita plus ou
moins dans mon bâtiment on a des
systèmes qui font que l'air qui remplit
l'air qui sort se croisent sans se
toucher donc pas de contamination de la
crise alors qu'ils rentrent et on est
capable de transférer l'énergie de l'air
chaud sur l'air froid qui rentrent
jusqu'à 90 % et même plus parfois donc
on est capable de garder toute la
chaleur dans laquelle on a on investit
on a dépensé l'énergie pour la produits
pour la garder à l'intérieur en prie
chauffe en l'air qui nous rend de
l'extérieur donc ça encore une fois
c'est des systèmes qui sont un peu caché
le toit vert vous en faisiez vous en
faisiez mention le toit vert plusieurs
caractéristiques plusieurs avantages en
ville par exemple à montréal on a un
problème de la gestion des autres pluie
quand il pleut très très fort et
beaucoup de surface qui n'absorbe pas
l'eau ça fasse imperméable mais toute
cette eau là s'en va dans les égouts
puis malheureusement on un système
d'égout qui n'est pas complètement
séparée donc les eaux pluviales se
mélange aux eaux aux eaux sales et tout
ça s'en va à notre station d'épuration
la station d'épuration a fait ce qu
apple essaye de traiter ça les toits
verts un des grands avantages que qu'on
leur prête c'est qu'ils absorbent l'eau
au lieu de la renvoyer dans le système
d'égout comme n'importe quel toit plat
ils vont garder l'eau et donc les égouts
vont en bénéficier dans un sens il fut
lui même utilisé dans l'ue dans les
toiles à si en plus ça on le voit dans
les toilettes s'est inscrit loki qui
finit par passer à travers le toit vert
on la récupère et on l'envoie dans un
réservoir on la traite de façon très
simple très sommaire et on veut la
réinjecter dans les toilettes parce que
on n'a pas besoin d'une eau potable dans
nos toilettes bien que au québec on est
de l'eau potable à
perpétuité on est là on est une
ressource mondiale pour l'eau potable
les toilettes n'ont jamais requise d'eau
potable ont besoin d eau propre on veut
pas que ça sente les égouts dans nos
toilettes mais on n'a pas besoin que
l'eau soit potable à la maison n'est
peut-être pas obligé de faire fermer on
peut peut-être avoir des toilettes qui
sont moins peut avoir des pôles est
moins consommatrices effectivement et
c'est un virage que notre société que
les consommateurs ont réussi à faire
avant on avait des toilettes dans les
années 80 des toilettes qui consommaient
18 litres à chaque chasse peut donc
petit petite chasse aux gros chat
s'était 18 litres d'eau à chaque fois
aujourd'hui ces produits là sont bannis
on les retrouve plus du tout sur les
tablettes ce qui est proposé si c'est
des trucs beaucoup plus et beaucoup plus
économe donc six lettres
4.83 lite parfois
j'ai fait le calcul rapidement famille
de quatre qui changerait d'une toilette
conventionnelle à une toile est normal
on parle de trois quatre piscines hors
terre d'eau sauvé par année donc c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment substantielle
temps de reparler de du petit apport que
chaque citoyen peut avoir mais quand on
regarde les chiffres de proches c'est
pas si petit comme un porc on accumule
tout ça en plus l'impact est très grand
l'urinoir ces chiffres et on disait que
depuis son installation ce sont 700
mille litres d'eau qui ont été
épargnées sauver donc bon allez c'est
une bonne chose évidemment
les petits gestes qui à grande échelle
fonfon différence joignent à d'autres
questions oui alors une question qui
nous provient de facebook thérèse
gabriel quartier qui dit on vit dans une
province où l'électricité est abondante
et provient d'une ressource renouvelable
l'autre alors que comment se fait-il que
nous ne soyons pas inonder de bornes de
recharge pour voitures électriques
alors peut-être qu'on peut élargir aussi
au sujet du transport
il demande des nouveaux véhicules qui me
sont offertes
je
pense que ça commence et c'est commencer
encore là il ya des municipalités qui
ont été des des modèles qui ont initié
le mouvement avec évidemment aidé au
québec qui a un programme
visant à inviter les municipalités à se
constituer une banque de bornes et en
faire
une fois que les municipalités sont
engagés dans ce processus là et que les
bornes sont en place mais il ya une
publicité qui est faite à l'échelle
nationale et qui nous disent si vous
alliez dans telle ville il ya tel ou tel
thème bob et ça ça s'en vient c'est
comment ça fait partie je regarde chez
nous ça fait partie des deux derniers
budgets on a dit on va installer
quelques-unes par année et lentement
mais sûrement on aura des on aura un
circuit de bord qui va être utilitaire à
la fois aux gens de chez nous mais aux
gens qui viennent d'ailleurs celui chez
nous par exemple initier les
l'institution cas initié sur chez nous
c'est le collège de ces jeunes dans sa
perspective doit être plus vert or ils
ont installé des bornes les ans dont
deux essais des étudiants qui utilisent
maintenant c'est sebag là c'est assez
extraordinaire saison c'est eux qui nous
ont pointé du doigt disant faites votre
fête va pas maintenant mais c'est parti
il y en a de plus en plus même encore la
petite municipalité grandes
municipalités autour des hôtels de ville
il ya des bornes maintenant qu'ils sont
installés et lentement mais sûrement on
est en train de se bâtir un circuit
intéressant un ciel va publier son plan
d'électrification 2015 2020 ils ont
promis des investissements de l'ordre de
3 500 millions de dollars vers les
véhicules vers le véhicule électrique
verra une grosse industrie d'un du
véhicule électrique au québec donc c'est
aussi une opportunité de croissance pour
la province et ils ont même promis une
réduction d'impôt de 8000 dollars pour
l'achat d'un véhicule vert pour ceux qui
sont intéressés donc ces véhicules reste
super cher mais peut récupérer eu 1000 $
autres
j'aurais même d'autres questions oui il
ya des gens qui s'intéressent par
exemple au pollueur payeur est ce que ce
que vous nous en dire un peu plus sur
les entreprises
c'est ce que c'est qu'un petit serait
viable à la bourse du carbone
ouais c'est ça l'exemple le plus concret
je pense hélas le marché des changes des
droits émission qui existe au québec et
bientôt en ontario en 2017 donc les plus
gros pollueurs en fait on leur donne une
un budget maximum d'émissions de gaz à
effet de serre tous les ans ils doivent
ils doivent payer pour ses émissions
jusqu'au plafond ils doivent démontrer
soit qu'ils sont
soit qu'ils ont acheté des crédits
compensatoires qui sont restés au sein
même du plafond
et bon nombres de provinces comme le
québec l'ontario rond et créer ce marché
des changes du carbone justement parce
que le le principe c'est que en
libéralisant si vous voulez les changes
du carbone on va pouvoir profiter de
réduction de carbone qui serait moins
cher que de le faire chez soi même donc
certaines entreprises ont des
opportunités de réduction qui sont plus
bon marché que d'autres mais
généralement est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que les entreprises ont
davantage envie de payer vu le faible
coût du carbone dans bien des cas ou
encore de modifier leur comportement à
la fois d'un point de vue économique et
d'un point de vue environnemental
mais ça dépend la plupart d'entreprises
font un calcul en plus il s'agit de
grosses entreprises qui sont réglementés
par ces marchés là ils font un calcul de
type économique très très simple quoi
donc il ils font leurs inventaires de
gaz à effet de serre ils sont obligés de
rapporter leurs inventeurs de gaz à
effet de serre et au gouvernement
ensuite ils voient les opportunités de
réduction quels sont les coûts de ces
opportunités direction a pour chaque
tonne de carbone qui vont réduire il
compare ça au prix du carbone sur le
marché
clairement quand quand c'est plus quand
c'est moins cher d'acheter la tonne de
carbone sur le marché que de réduire
chez chez eux ils vont ils vont
l'acheter ceci dit mme y prennent
également en compte le
l'amélioration de l'efficience des
processus et c'est en améliorant la
consommation de carbone dans leur
entreprise donc là où ça fait sens ils
vont réduire chez eux sinon ils vont
général qui est qui revient souvent dans
les médias sociaux puisque j'ai
enregistré souvent et le recyclage
servier souvent les gens qui disent ça
nous donne rien de recycler c'est pour
recycler le verre par exemple est ce que
est ce que c'est un mythe et qui
monsieur lapointe dentition parfaite il
ya actuellement
dans les dernières années on établissait
les produits qu'ils étaient exclus du
moins ce qu'on mettait dans le bac bleu
il y en a 15 % qui se rediriger qui
était pas récupérable véritablement et
qui seraient requis étaient redirigées
vers les sites d'enfouissement sanitaire
les derniers chiffres qu'on a c'est 13%
donc eu une amélioration
à ce niveau là et moi je pense que à
mesure qu'on avance dans le temps à
mesure que les technologies
se développent
j'ai donné l'exemple de victoriaville
tout à l'heure la performance devrait
éventuellement s'améliorer quoique
encore sur le plan du recyclage on a
atteint un certain plateau et il
faudrait que des produits qui sont pas
considérés comme
recyclables puisse devenir cyclables je
vous donne un exemple vous vous jetez
des feuilles de papier dans votre bac
bleu ça fonctionne bouge tes un livre
dans le bac bleu ça c'est pas considéré
comme recyclades et pourtant c'est du
papier mais il ya un couvert et tout ça
donc ça fait pas partie du spectre des
matières qui devrait être
recyclés à la dans le contexte il faut
que les producteurs
et pour entreprises par exemple qui gère
la production des deux s'est produit est
recyclable à éventuellement qui j'avais
une partie de ce qui est récupéré des
industries qui produisent les
producteurs dont il faudrait que le
spectre des plastiques par exemple soit
soit élargi on ramasse les produits du
mérou en numéro 2 possiblement que le
numéro toile d'une erreur quatre parties
claires et saab est ce qu'on peut
demander aux citoyens à l'intérieur de
commencer à analyser et à regarder
ce qui est inscrit sur la barquette des
bas salaires le cyclable celle là l'est
pas faut élargir ce spectre et là ce qui
nous permettra éventuellement de den
osse le pourcentage de matières
recyclables qui est récupéré des dés la
gestion des matières résiduelles et l'a
fait d'arriver à une meilleure
performance
mais là il faut développer des
technologies faut faire un choc les
caries ses besoins par se produire pour
les remettre sur le marché donc façon le
vert et quand je vous ai parlé tout à
l'heure de l'exemple de victoriaville il
ya en plus des plastiques danse et dès
qu'il ya du vert donc il ya maintenant
de façon de récupérer le verre et de le
traiter de le remettre sur le circuit
sans que ce soit des bouteilles
tricentris notre organisation fait aussi
une gestion du verre qui lui permet de
faire des sous produits à ce douloureux
on avance lentement mais sûrement mais
là la solution à ce qui est demandé et
ce qui est relié à la question faut
élargir ce spectre de produits qu'on
doit risques éventuels et peut-être
éduquer davantage madame lessard moi je
dirais à cette dame là qu'il faut pas
arrêter les bonnes habitudes qu'on a
pris en ce moment la recherche s penche
sur ces questions-là de valorisation de
ces produits là qu'ils ont bon il y en a
le vert c'est un coq bien spécifiques il
ya des matériaux composites qui sont
étudiées pour
paver les rues pour concevoir des objets
il faut miser là-dessus faut pas perdre
la bonne habitude ce que j'ajouterai à
ça c'est que ça ça fait partie des 3
hervé qu'on connaît bien réutilisez
recyclez
réduire valorisé mais il y en a deux
autres arts ça s'est recyclé il ya aussi
réutilisés et réduire j'ai déjà entendu
et c'est pas c'est juste pour montrer à
quel point on est des surconsommateurs
c'est que des fois on est donc satisfait
de notre bac qui est bien rempli leurs
citoyens proactif et je m'envole lui
porter seul ajoute le jour de la
collecte je me sens bien quelque part
pourquoi qui est plein pourquoi j'ai
surconsommer qu'est-ce que j'ai acheté
temps alors il ya aussi cette notion-là
de finalement réduire à la source au
lieu d'un recyclé qui va qui en fait qui
éviterait bien des problèmes avec le
verre par exemple voilà il aide le
suremballage est ce que les entreprises
sont sensibilisés à ce parce qu'on a
l'impression qu'on nous en parle
beaucoup mais on retrouve encore tous
les produits suremballés est ce que ça
bouge
le suremballage moi je dois avouer je
travaille pas beaucoup avec les
entreprises de je donnerai un exemple au
dictionnaire on en arrive à la période
des faits qu'il allait acheter un parfum
l'acheteur parfum vous avez la petite
boîte avec sa bouteille de parfum la
deuxième boîte et la troisième bois le
sla emballages en papier qui revient là
dessus alors qu'on peut se pencher là
dessus ce qu'on peut standardisés aussi
un peu plus les emballages vous allez au
à l'épicerie vous avez deux boîtes de
céréales la super jumbo la familiale la
moyenne et la petite alors un moment
donné la touche assez d éléments oui ça
répond à des besoins des consommateurs
mais quel effort est fait pour arriver à
standardiser à dire bon ça votre sens de
la formule et ça va tout seul le type
d'emballage on va en rester à ça ça se
multiplie et sa basse et des opérations
marketing
c'est encore de répondre aux souhaits de
grands consommateurs
ce que moyen de faire la moitié du
chemin à ce niveau-là et de réduire une
partie ou de standardiser davantage
j'ajouterai peut-être l'emballage serre
liées au transport aux 6 1 c'est sûr que
le
marketing est lié à la petite boîte
belle mais ya beaucoup de suremballage
aussi dans l'est dans les matériaux con
con qu'on consomme des balles et une
fois qu'ils sont rendus dans nos
magasins donc encore une fois choisir
des matériaux qui nous proviennent de
distance plus courte des matériaux
locaux un marché on parlait de
nourriture tout à l'heure ce qui pose
tout mon domaine mais pour moi c'est
clair que si j'achète un légume qui a
été cultivé à 50 km de chez moi il fort
probable que le cultivateur pas eu
besoin de lamballe et le suremballés
pour le protéger pendant pendant son
transport je pense que choisir des
produits
plus locaux va encourager le à diminuer
le suremballage justement comme sa
joie alors sur radio canada.ca en
nageant savoir qu'ils demandent pourquoi
les nord américains sont peu enclins à
penser à l'énergie solaire qu'on ne dise
est une boule d'énergie qui est encore
disponible pour 5 milliards d'années et
qu en europe ça a été davantage
démocratique ici alors j'aimerais vous
entendre
mais patinage solaire la ccl l'énergie
probablement du futur on se le cachera
pas c'est une énergie qui est
extrêmement puissante à chaque demi
heure sur terre on reçoit autant
d'énergie que ce qu'on consomme dans une
année donc on n'est pas du tout rendu à
pouvoir récolter tout ça il va falloir
faire des efforts mais pourquoi en
amérique du nord je serais peut-être pas
je sais pas pour le reste du canada il
ya certainement une un aspect
technologique parce que les technologies
photovoltaïques
c'est un peu comme les voitures hybrides
ou voitures électriques cc des
technologies qui sont qui vont permettre
de créer une énergie ou une consommation
propre mais en arrière de tout ça il ya
des procédés qui sont très énergivores
qui sont très polluants fabriquer des
panneaux solaires ou disposer panneaux
solaires c'est pas évident que c'est que
c'est propre
au québec on a on est très très très
choyé point de vue énergétique on a fait
le choix de l'hydroélectricité il ya
quelques dizaines d'années et ça c'est
une énergie qui heureusement propre
hockey et qui est qui qui traite
facilement disponible est en très grande
quantité au québec alors ça ça fait que
le prix de l'électricité le prix de ces
énergies là est très faible et son
impact environnemental aussi faible donc
vouloir faire le changement pour passer
des panneaux solaires sur notre maison
quand on paye en scène de kilowattheures
d'hydroélectricité il ya un aspect il ya
un aspect économique et même écologique
n'est pas qui n'est pas évident pour moi
que c'est ça l'enjeu majeur c'est qu'en
fait on a l'impression qu'il ya des les
ordres au québec sont souvent très très
contestée mais ce qu'on se rend pas
compte c'est qu'on paie l'électricité
vraiment pêcheurs puissent se sache ça
fera pas changer les comportements la
même chose pour l'oim on est des
surconsommateurs de ces ressources là
qu'on a en abondance et c'est au québec
donc tant qu'on paye repos pour ça il
n'y aura pas de changement vers
l'efficacité énergétique c'est
principalement pour ce oui il ya des
défauts au niveau technologique des
défis au niveau de la gestion des
déchets parce que il ya des défis au
niveau des ressources qu'on parlait
plutôt le lithium et le cobalt ou ci
intervient bien on ad'autres le remède
et des métaux rares qui intervient dans
la fabrication des panneaux solaires au
delà de stuff c'est pourquoi qu'on
n'arrive pas à changer les habitudes on
paye plus cher son comparé à comparer
son comparer avec l'europe présente pour
miser sur la voiture électrique et
toutes ces technologies pour lesquelles
on est vraiment nouveau pour moi je vais
je vais ramener encore ce que j'ai dit
un peu plus tôt mais la voiture
électrique oui oui mais faut faire
attention de prendre en compte tous les
ans parce qu'on risque de déplacer des
problèmes
consommer plus d'électricité va générer
plus de barrage va faire en sorte que
l'importation exportation d'électricité
votre débat lancé que ça va affecter
tout le reste globalement c'est pas
juste au niveau local que vous regardez
soucis au niveau global si on parle en
termes de grs qui sont globales et non
locale
je peux rajouter un petit point là
dessus
poser les panneaux solaires sur une
maison où acheter une voiture électrique
si
on peut être rendu là dépendamment de
notre situation mais je dirais que c'est
comme le dernier geste à faire quand on
ne fait tout le reste avant de m'acheter
ma voiture électrique je vais peut-être
essayer de voir qu'est ce que je
pourrais changer dans mon mode de
déplacement est ce que je peux pas me
rapprocher ce que je peux pas prendre le
transport en commun est ce que je peux
pas habiter à côté de mon travail à ce
que je peux faire du télétravail à la
place si malgré toutes ces petites
choses là tout ces petits changements
qui ne manquent beaucoup moins d'énergie
grise dans le domaine de l'analyse de
cycle de vie l'énergie grise c'est toute
l'énergie qu'on ne voit paul qui est
consommée par un objet ou par un choix
est ce que est ce que je peux changer
plein de petites choses pour ne pas
avoir à m'acheter un panneau panneaux
solaires est ce que je peux changer mais
ma consommation ma façon de consommer
mon électricité dans ma maison en
faisant attention si je pose des
panneaux solaires sur ma maison mais que
je fais pas attention de fermer mes
lumières quand je quitte ou de baisser
le chauffage un peu la nuit ou d'autres
mesures très simples à faire ça aucun
sens donc la même façon des voitures
électriques on va essayer de faire tout
ce qu'on peut faire avant d'utiliser la
voiture électrique parce qu'en face il
est vrai problème c'est l'auto
dépendance que ça amène des défis au
niveau des banlieues et tout se sait sur
moi je me penche beaucoup sur ces
questions là j'essaie de trouver des
solutions puis j'aimerais ça vous
entendent imprimer à montréal on n'a pas
besoin de voiture on en a pas besoin
sincèrement que même ses encombrants une
voiture c'est difficile pour le
stationnement faut changer d'un côté de
l'autre et ça c'est pas la vie de
quartier moi j'ai pas de voiture j'ai
une vie de quartier je me déplace en
transport actif collectif je marche j'ai
réappris à marcher j'ai réappris à faire
du vélo
j'ai vraiment réalisé exactement en
banlieue il ya quand même tout cet enjeu
lors de la conception de l'aménagement
du territoire et dans les petites
solutions simples que je me dis qu'est
ce qu'en banlieue on préfère que c'est
peut-être juste par ménage le dirai ce
que j'ai vraiment besoin de deux ou
trois voitures peut-être de limiter de
partage et de covoiture ips moi
j'aimerais vous entendre là dessus ben
chaussée
un élément mais faire ou développer le
transport actif c'est une autre chose
qui apparaît intéressant
nous on vit actuellement depuis quelques
années d expérience on a
augmenté élargi notre notre réseau de
pistes cyclables
l'interrompt l'intégrer aux
réparations la mise à jour de nos
infrastructures on a fait des travaux
extérieurs dont p cyclable sentiers
piétonniers et première chose qu'on
s'est rendu compte c'est lorsqu'on
développe un espace accessible pour les
piétons ou pour les vélos les gens la
vraie force et
dansaient c'est un gage de succès donc
pour nous et pas seulement pour nous
mais pour bien d'autres municipalités de
développer ses réseaux intérieurs la
d'inviter les gens se transporte
d'actifs là les gens vont accéder puis
vous avez parlé d'identification de
territoire de façon indirecte ça aussi
l'étalement urbain même pour les
communautés qui sont en dehors de des
grands centres urbains là aussi
l'étalement occasion justement
l'obligation de prendre une voiture d'en
avoir deux tout ça donc là aussi des
changements pratiques en a parlé des
changements de pratiques faut que ça
vienne aussi des utilisateurs faut que
ça vienne des citoyens aussi dit que bon
c'est à leur tour de faire leur part à
ce niveau là mais il faut leur fournir
les moyens profère
joannes que dans les questions d enjeu
particulièrement important qu'on aurait
oublié de parler malgré cette brochette
d'invités sinon j'ai une question du
public ici peut-être que jean-louis
j'aurais juste peut-être compléter avec
est-ce que les entreprises on parle
souvent des entreprises qui sont bons au
niveau des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre qu'ils émettent mais justement est
ce que dans les politiques auprès des
travailleurs des incitatifs par exemple
pour du télétravail des trucs comme ça
c'est ce que les entreprises voient ce
que vous conseiller les entreprises en
cette matière je connais pas avant
d'incitatifs officielle pour
pour promouvoir le télétravail
maintenant la plupart grosse boîte
commence à inciter leurs employés à
rester à la maison travaillé depuis la
maison travailler dans des cafés etc
je pense que les recherches psychosocial
aussi montré que améliorer cette balance
de vie entre travail et maison aussi
entraîne des des gains de productivité
donc il ya d'autres raisons qui font
qu'on occulte et travail fait sens
mais maintenant il ya plein
d'initiatives je crois que le québec le
provincial avait un programme
covoiturage ou i là où il assistait les
employeurs les pme qui qui voulait
promouvoir le covoiturage
au sein de leurs employés il leur
apporter une aide financière justement
pour pour les aider à faire sa manière
modérée économique
merci on a deux questions le concernant
il n'y a jugé au thermique on a très peu
parlé ici moi je suis pas mal d'énergie
un annuaire et dix agneaux points comme
en france dont les vedettes dernièrement
adro une apprenait que va faire quelque
chose de rare rapport à l'indienne
d'année + 1 10 franc 26 les autres à
leur
procès contre accord sur tout notre être
renner a présenté la fracture tu as
gardé très critiques de compagnies je
suis produit sur place géothermie tu
peux chaufferie peut-être mais la
remarque tout de même beaucoup de
maisons à 88 4 5 vous le plus âgé des
mails à l'intérieur c'est pas trés rata
vous l'avez su de la géothermie mais pas
quand arrive une perche une marque
chaque faute de main devient très
intéressant choses bougent les autres à
la gabelle pour la géothermie
d'affaires loge thomas vache folle des
maisons sur celle qui s'attrape
d'hypothèques et de logement il s'occupa
de rien de trop longs jours hier et
partagent la facture cette semaine en
une maison y a pas de spectacle pour
vérifier quatre cantons soumis aux
nobles
justement au niveau de la géothermie est
ce qu'on est rendus là lors de la
construction de 10 ici par exemple est
ce que ça aurait été pertinent jusqu'à
un meuble à j 6 et 6 ans pour sa
géothermique font pourtant selon
plusieurs puits en arrière la géothermie
c'est ça revient à ce qu'on disait tout
à l'heure le prix de l'électricité en
électricité qui a quelques unes
réputation d'être propre encaissé pas du
nucléaire ou du charbon spots du mazout
on a une énergie relativement propre et
on l'a vraiment en grande quantité donc
elle est vraiment pas cher quand on
quand on parle d'acheter un de faire
forer des puits géothermiques installer
des machines comme ça c'est vrai qu'à
petite échelle ça coûte extrêmement cher
aux particuliers ce n'est pas du tout
bête en tout cas pas pour tous en tout
cas
envisageable d'investir peut-être 50 40
50 mille dollars à la chaîne notre
maison pour avoir notre géothermie et un
chauffage presque gratuit c'est vrai que
dans des grands projets effectivement on
devrait inciter les grands consommateurs
dans les grandes tours les gros projets
les gros bâtiments les centres
commerciaux tout ça à investir parce
qu'ils vont de toute façon exquis avis
le seul sur des très grandes profondeurs
leur coût d'installation de cm2 de
système là va être beaucoup plus réduit
que particuliers puis la rentabilité va
vous être prête au rendez vous
la deuxième question c'est est-ce que la
schl fed et à ma connaissance lorsqu'on
bâti selon le code du bâtiment et ceci
je travaille à l'occasion avec un groupe
montréalais qui s'appelle et
cohabitation peut on a beaucoup milité
pour que dans le nouveau code du
bâtiment on exige une inspection
d'infiltrométrie l'on appelle son test
d'infiltrométrie ion on gonfle la maison
et on regarde nous excuse où sont les
fuites d'air parce que les fuites d'air
d'une maison le celi à peu près 40% de
notre facture d'électricité donc c'est
ici c'est un enjeu majeur
le nouveau code malheureusement exige de
sceller certains endroits mais ne vient
pas vérifier donc pas de test qui est
fait il n'ya pas de suivi ça s'est un
peu déplorable est ce que les prochains
code 2d l'exigé c'est un test qui coûte
vraiment pas cher à faire c'est très
simple ça selon moi ça devrait être ça
devrait être la base quelque chose que
autant d'impact sur la consommation
énergétique devrait être inscrit dans le
code par contre il existe des programmes
comme aujourd'hui il existe nouveau
climat deux versions 2.0
lorsque vous inscrivez à ce programme là
il ya des subventions qui s'y qui s'y
rattachent et là vous avez un test
d'infiltrométrie un test d'étanchéité
qui fait sur votre votre habitation mais
c'est un programme qui qu'on fait de
façon volontaire c'est pas du tout
quelque chose qui est obligé par le par
le code du de construction
autre question
du désinfectant
aujourd'hui quand on construit selon le
code du bâtiment
il n'ya pas d'inspection au niveau
résidentiel on va dire le peu
d'inspections qui est fait pour ce qui
est de l'efficacité énergétique
deviendra peut-être
autres le cas puisqu'on parle de
solutions mais le climat j'aimerais
souligner l'initiative du jour de la
terre de plants et 375 mille arbres à
montréal donc je vous invite à aller
voir leur site web de donner 10 dollars
pour acheter un arbre je pense qu'un
juste assez important l'université
mémorial aussi qu' un projet aussi de
planter des arbres pour décontaminer du
terrain on a beaucoup de terrains
contaminés à moyens qui sont inutilisés
donc pourquoi pas planter des arbres sur
ses terres et nos pour décontaminer un
terrain qui ne vaut rien en ce moment
que ce qui est des contaminés qui
coûterait une fortune à décontaminer
donc en dix ans il pourrait totalement
décontaminer que je dis souvent et en
même temps apporter plusieurs valeurs
foncières et cetera aussi aide et
beaucoup les îlots de chaleur on n'a pas
parlé beaucoup des lots de challans
aussi c'est un aspect important qu'il
faudrait parler
si rots et les chercheurs qui s'y font
partie du sirop de là on n'est pas faire
attention façon de le dire on
s'intéresse beaucoup à ce verdissement
urbain là et le lien à faire avec la
santé mais en fait avec toute l'ailé les
hyperliens qu'on peut faire avec les
îlots de chaleur avec l'agriculture
urbaine avec la qualité de l'air avec le
fait que c'est agréable d'être entourée
d'arbres on a juste à se promener dans
les rues de montréal quand que des armes
pilotes comme en ce moment qu'un canot
tinqueux portefeuille sais c'est pas le
même montréal qu'on connaît donc
verdissement urbain oui faut miser
là-dessus faut juste par contre faire
attention peut faire les mêmes gars
qu'on a déjà fait puis quand on est déjà
fait dans le passé avec les chaînes et
qu'on a fait actuellement avec les
freine c'est à dire de reboiser
seulement une espèce surtout avec les
changements climatiques parce que tout
ce qui est éco systèmes écosystémiques
est en train de se déplacer ça amène des
parasites ça a même qui on risque de
plus avoir d'armée à montréal à cause
qu'on a à boiser reboiser seulement avec
une espèce inondant la biodiversité
biodiversité exactement ce que plus
verts aux alentours c'est peut-être ce
qu'on a derrière nous à ce moment oui je
me trompe pas le petit le petit terrain
qui est à côté fin de partie du projet
puis c'était un requis pour pour la
ville
ou pour le projet je peux je peux dire
n'importe quoi mais le bâtiment occupe
vraiment tout son terrain mais on a
permis d'avoir un parc à côté donc à peu
près la même empreinte
en végétation à côté du but avec de la
verdure à côté également le temps file
et vous avez même faudrait pas prendre
trop de co2 je voyais dans les notes un
peu amusantes je voyais dans les 10
recommandations de la cap 21 dont je
vous parlais un peu plus tôt éteindre
les appareils électriques en ville on
comprendra qu'on a des caméras d'ouverte
des systèmes d'éclairage et ça fait
aussi partie des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre en bout de piste et tout
ça pour vous dire que par rapport
justement technologies j'entends en fin
de semaine à l'émission la sphère à
radio-canada très bonne émission par
ailleurs que les internet de façon
générale les maîtresses aujourd'hui à
peu près autant de co2 que le transport
par avion donc comme quoi les recherches
sur internet font fonctionner des
serveurs tout ça ça aussi une empreinte
au début on parlait du des deux voyages
par avion par année la personne qui
sentait mal je sais pas jusqu'où on doit
aller dans tout ça et si vous avez une
recherche à faire sur un moteur de
recherche à quel point on doit s'en
priver mais quand même ça ça nous montre
que les les technologies changent et on
s'en va aussi ailleurs par rapport à
tout ça donc non on n'arrête pas au bout
de deux heures en raison de nos
émissions mais faudra le faire quand
même ce sera peut être notre raison
enfin la raison qu'on se donnera mais
avant de terminer je me joins laisse
quand même question quelle personne
micro je le voyais pas derrière la
caméra très rapidement parce que on
arrive à la fin oui bon je suis
étudiante en communication
internationale à l'uqam et je
m'intéresse pas mal auprès matinée
développements j'aurais voulu juste
parler des questions de sensibilisation
autour du développement durable je pense
qu'aujourd'hui au gouvernement il manque
pas mal de pros de professionnels de la
communication qui travaillent autour de
stratégies durables pour sensibiliser
les jeunes notamment mais voilà c'est un
pan que voulait soulever deuxième point
que je voulais que je voulais soulever
c'était concernant le contrôle des
entreprises aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui se
passe réellement dans le contrôle des
entreprises notamment par rapport aux
déchets et ce qu'ils ont pas mieux
finalement à payer factures une fois
tous les dix ans que d'investir dans des
vraies stratégies
durables on va dire auprès de l'écologie
peut-être monsieur amadou sur cette
question là et on conclura chacun votre
tour donc si vous avez quelque chose qui
vous horripile ou qui s'indigne par
rapport aux comportements des citoyens
est le message que vous voudriez envoyé
en définitive mais évidemment répondant
à madame oui au niveau du contrôle des
entreprises et de leur empreinte ce que
je vais parler de l'empreinte carbone
pas de l'ensemble des impacts
environnementaux
donc ce qui se passe c'est que la
plupart des provinces canadiennes ont un
système de de monétisation du carbone
donc les plus gros pollueurs doivent
payer pour pouvoir polluer en tout cas
pouvoir émettre des tonnes de gaz à
effet de serre ce qui se passe cette
entreprise-là devra porter de manière
annuelle leurs émissions ensuite payé
pour les émissions qui vont au delà d'un
certain budget et mettre en place des
investissements qui visent à réduire la
plupart de ces dans la plupart système
là le gouvernement a publié les cibles
de réduction sur 5 ans ou même dix ans
le québec haddad et si jusqu'en 2030
donc les entreprises connaissent
l'objectif final en fait du granon pas
finale mais intermédiaire si vous voulez
et sont capables de prédire
l'augmentation du prix du carbone au fur
et à mesure que ces opportunités de
réduction finalement se réduisent donc
elles ont quand même incités à mettre en
place d'investissement est vraiment
réduire leurs émissions parce qu'ils
savent que le prix du carbone va
continuer à augmenter
après au niveau des pratiques qui
m'horripile ou le message d'espoir que
vous voudriez envoyer la cap 21 on a eu
un beau message d'espoir des ouïes
élèves qui étaient là bas mais au-delà
de ça qu'est ce qui serait là lorsqu'on
sort d'ici le geste le plus peut-être au
niveau des entreprises ont le plus
pertinent à faire mais moi je travaille
en matière de changement climatique de
plus de 10 ans maintenant et même pour
moi quand je suis rendu au magasin et je
dois faire un choix de consommation
c'est difficile je ne sais pas moi même
quels produits achetés pour réduire mon
empreinte environnementale ou mon
empreinte climat donc j'irai une
démesure dans lesquels on devrait
investir plus des forces et l'étiquetage
l'étiquetage environnemental
l'étiquetage carbone pouvoir aider les
gens justement à faire cet arbitrage la
cua et l'autre mesure qui est en cours
d'acheminement c'est un petit peu de de
changer les distorsions de prix pourquoi
ce qu'ils épluchent moins cher d'acheter
des choses qu'ils viennent de chine qui
ont une empreinte carbone lourde que
d'acheter des produits qui sont
québécois ou canadiens c'est un gros
problème qu'il faut un il faut adresser
monsieur lapointe votre mot de la fin je
vous la fais je pense qu'on réalise dans
les propos qu'on a vu tout le monde
ensemble chaque citoyen
peut avoir un effet sur et un impact sur
l'atteinte des objectifs fixés par le
gouvernement chaque citoyen rajouter un
ses voisins à son environnement peut
amener une ville change évidemment son
son empreinte à la moi je pense que des
phares qui est affaire vient d'abord et
avant tout de chacun des personnes
changements d'habitudes
d'adopter de meilleures façons de vivre
ça ça change pas les orientations des
projets qu'on peut avoir mais de faire
cet effort là c'est pas compliqué c'est
ça donne des résultats immédiats
évidemment il le faire savoir à leurs
élus pour d'affaires pour qu'ils
emboîtent le pas et le plus rapidement
possible tout à fait madame lessard j'ai
deux messages clic 1 qui en lien avec
votre commentaire c'est je pense je me
suis toujours un peu plus dans la
philosophie ou encore les questions
de fond et je crois qu'il faut
s'attarder un petit peu faut faire
davantage de recherches pour comprendre
qu est ce qui fait qu on passe d'une
intention à une action donc les
communications la psychologie et où je
crois que c'est des soins des
disciplines qu'on sort du développement
durable mais il ya beaucoup de choses à
faire et à rapporter et de loges et même
mon prochain point qui est d'apprendre à
travailler de façon interdisciplinaire
multidisciplinaire donc le génie avec
les sciences sociales mais au-delà de
cela avec le citoyen avec le secteur
privé avec les municipalités le
gouvernement les organisations qui sont
puis ça c'est un défi on sait pas trop
encore comment faire ça mais moi je
pense que si elle est là la clé fait la
psychologie et après on a travaillé
ensemble j'occupe puisqu'on fait en
sortant d'ici on était les lumières
problème aussi j'ai comme 2,2 points
majeurs le peut être résumée
l'éducation la technologie l'éducation
l'éducation l'éducation
je pense que plus on est informé tout à
leur parler de victoriaville moi j'ai eu
l'occasion de donner des conférences à
victoriaville pour informer les citoyens
qui à des tels programmes qui existent
telles choses que vous pouvez faire dans
leurs propres bus dans leur propre ville
plus les gens sont informés plus vont
vouloir embarquer je pense pas que
fondamentalement l'être humain soit
contre l'économie d'énergie l'économie
des ressources mais il s'agit de les
informer donc cette première soit
deuxième c'est de garder parce que nous
on est dans un jeu dirais pas
microclimat mais on est dans une
situation privilégiée on a de
l'électricité propre de l'énergie propre
on est un pays riche mais gardez en tête
que la terre c'est comme un bateau on
est tous sur le même bateau si demain
moi je décide de me rendre plus vers un
polluant chez le voisin l'effet l'effet
final l'effet global va être le même
donc on a parlé d' analyse de cycle de
vie c'est de voir tous nos gestes dans
un ensemble et quand on décide d'aller
dans une direction de penser aux
répercussions que en dehors de chine ou
en dehors de notre recours en dehors de
notre pays
et tout ça va nous aider a visé dans le
fond le geste le plus simple et puis je
reviens sur ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure avant d'aller au geste le plus
complexe d'acheter des panneaux solaires
d'acheter des voitures pensons à la base
pensant à tout ce qu'on peut faire de
simples un changement de nos habitudes
qui a presque pas d'impact sur note sur
notre mode de vie mais qui peut avoir
lorsqu'on l'a cumule un gros impact
fort intéressant merci à vous tous donc
en terminant je rappelle vous ou non est
ce que vous faites au cas où quelqu'un
voudrait vous recontacter par la suite
s'est passé jacques est consultant en
développement en bâtiment durable et
chargé de cours à l'école de technologie
supérieure de montréal madame isabelle
lessard vous êtes coordonnatrice
scientifique au centre
interdisciplinaire de recherche en
opérationnalisation du développement
durable si rod deux associés à
polytechnique sur le maire denis
lapointe maire de salaberry de
valleyfield et président de la
commission du développement durable à
l'union des municipalités du québec et
monsieur jean christophe amado directeur
en développement durable chez deloitte
conseiller donc les entreprises johan
merci ont repris beaucoup de questions
du public sur internet merci d'ailleurs
au public qui est ici à la maison du
développement durable à montréal et
merci beaucoup à tous ceux aussi qui
nous ont suivis sur les différentes
plateformes web la discussion peut
évidemment continuer et jusqu'à la fin
de la coop 21 de la conférence de paris
sur les changements climatiques qui vous
demandent plusieurs équipes qui sont sur
place vous pouvez suivre tous assure ici
point radio canada.ca barres obliques
climat merci beaucoup à la maison du
développement durable qui nous a
accueilli aujourd'hui c'est fort
agréable de tenir l'événement dans ce
lieu symbolique évidemment et merci à
louis
bouchard le diane qui réalisait cette
webdiffusion alors mears encore à tout
le monde et au plaisir de reparler de
tout ça
il